grave très très heureux de vous
retrouver quelques heures avant les
billets je vous laisse vous installer
confortablement pour passer les deux
prochaines heures ensemble gros
programme aujourd'hui vous avez vu on a
déjà des invités autour de nous lors de
la première heure on s'interrogera sur
comment intégrer des prospects mots et
les problématiques une salle engrange
pour ce faire je suis emploi et que de
l'autre hippiques on a le plaisir
d'accueillir jean christophe prat
qu'autre chose qui vient de monter en
fait clic clic avec le paris basket ball
bonsoir jean christophe bonsoir à tous
et nous avons aussi la voix ce soir
d'avoir le coach de l'année en pro b de
la saison 2020 2021 avec le sqbb julien
my bonsoir julien bonjour à tous enfin
il nous fallait l'oeil et le vécu
d'avoir un ordre international
lavaud miami litim denver nuggets de
nombreuses années en italie si yakhouba
diawara qui depuis usa va nous rejoindre
pour compléter notre plateau autre
membre historique le plus connu un est
un assistant coach heureux de la
performance de son équipe hier et
consultant draps sont bien sport romain
leroy salut romain le plus connu je sais
pas non plus penser surtout certainement
pas moi mais bon ce soir
pendant la première heure on
s'intéressera
à comment justement on peut faire
intégrer ces jeunes prospects et ensuite
on verra avec alan et pierre qui vont
nous rejoindre vous parlera de 4
prospects français pour un tram 2022 que
sont ils se mêlent kamagaté mienne
barbiche hugo besson qui a explosé
l'année dernière sqbb en provenance de
l'élan chalon et on finira par ousmane
dieng qui comme lego bus et hugo maison
pardon et partir rejoint la nba
comme d'habitude n'hésitez pas à poser
vos questions en live sur le tchat on va
faire un maximum pour y répondre
messieurs dames les présentations sont
faites on m'a rentré dans le vif du
sujet la première question est simple
pourquoi ce choix de faire confiance à
des joueurs kamagaté barbiche et begarin
pour jean-christophe hugo blesson
timothée base est la dernière et neftali
feliz cette saison pour julien
dijoux
rls l'honneur là là
je réponds que je me connais je vais le
way de quoi ça va
oui donc je disais par rapport
c'est ça
la f1
ouais jean-christophe que j'avais fait
le choix de faire confiance à des jeunes
pourquoi
depuis nos débuts
il ya pas de raison à ça
la première des raisons est que pense
que jean-christophe dire à la gauche
déjà on aime ça donc moi j'adore
travailler avec les jeunes gens à les
accompagner les aider
et leur montrer et l'accompagnement de
l'exigence du professionnel de
nombreuses on est que je pense quand je
suis arrivé à saint quentin un club qui
a quand même assez peu de moyens et j'ai
très vite dit au président que ça devait
être nos credo de faire venir des jeunes
joueurs et de les aider à se développer
et ça pouvait nous nous permettre
d'avoir
d'envoi en prêt de club 2 3
avec les départs qui
malgré sa part s'est d'ores-et-déjà
après
le vif du sujet si vous voulez sur hugo
plus particulièrement l'idée palais là
donc c'est pour
l'aspect réglementaire nous
qui quintino le fait qu'on n'a pas de
sens de formation des jeunes joueurs
demain
c'est
en plus on se cale à prouver
on n'entend plus julien j'ai passé la
main à agen à jean-christophe du bon
bonsoir bonsoir à tous
ben moi c'est assez simple je pense que
je suis un coach au part des choses
et j'ai été pas cette amende objectifs
de vie d'être
je ne vais commencer à m'entraîner
au et donc de
continuer sur quoi en crawl en quoi je
croyais
dans le monde professionnel voilà donc
je reste
j'ai envie de vous dire que je sais pas
comment fonctionnent les autres couches
qui entraîne avec des jeunes et serait
intéressant d'avoir l'avis de julien
mais
[Applaudissements]
j'essaye de les développer autant
techniquement et tactiquement
je m'occupe mots avec eux j'ai un regard
j'ai aussi un regard de papa dire que
j'ai un regard extra terrain qui est
assez fort
et c'est ce qui me fait globalement
c'est ce qui m'a toujours animé ce qui
ce qui me fait le plein ce qui fait
donc ce que j'ai bien compris c'est que
ces deux volonté réelle de votre part
déjà et on va s'intéresser à
10 équipes sur parti au niveau du
recrutement est ce que c'est spécifique
de recruter des jeunes joueurs comme ça
est ce que vous avez un réseau comment
vous faites justement
à voir se voir de boire égouts s'y lie à
kouba vous me posez c'est glee ce serait
cool
dit quoi
oui à quoi
bon temps abo bonsoir
montfort l'après midi à 14 heures
est
ce que est ce que pendant que tu butch
des choses tu peux mettre en minute s'il
te plaît
connexion est très très difficile
à bord a perdu julien du coq la voilà
alors tu veux répondre à ta question du
cui s'il te plaît alors ça s'est fait en
deux temps
puisqu'en fait
demain c'était un petit peu particulier
parce que
de denain comme certainement c'est le
cas avec avec julien c'est très
compliqué de faire venir des jeunes
joueurs
pour les signer tu les obtiens en prob
et aucun sou souvent les jeunes joueurs
en prêt après tu peux avoir des jeunes
joueurs pas aussi jeune mais en post
formation des joueurs qui ont à peu près
une vingtaine d'années
cela tu peux les signes et donc demain
ça s'est plus fait dans ce sens là
là la chance que que j'ai eu au paris
basket ball c'est que j'ai réussi
dès la première saison en a tiré en a
tiré quelques uns et dès la deuxième
saison a très vite a très vite pouvoir
signer juin à nice mais les et mylan et
donc du coup
bon j'ai envie de te dire que c'est ces
deux marchés différents le marseille de
la pro b en tout cas pour moi donne 1
était un marché où j'avais pas accès à
tous les jeunes joueurs que je
souhaitais parce que il faut que les
clubs pros accepte de te les prêter la
sueur depuis que j'ai au paris basket
ball c'est un petit peu différente et
c'est pour ça que j'en ai pris des plus
jeunes aussi parce que quand j'ai pris
mais joannie semelle et mylan il avait
17 18 et 18 en sachant en sachant si je
me trompe pas que quand tu es à denain
c'est la même problématique que julien à
55 avait pas l'agrément du centre de
formation et avait en plus par dessus
l'oublier sur réglementaire de faire
jouer les moins de 23 ans plus du en
plus de la volonté les faire jouer bien
sûr bien sûr mais ça c'était un truc ça
m'a jamais moi voilà
c'était le donneur ou un centre de
formation agréé ça serait resté comme ça
ça en sachant qu'à l'époque pour
resituer pour les gens taïz et la corde
signé comme joueur à jerry bouthier les
cas pas celle là bas il ya la combattre
alors la vierge ouattara ben non alors
la première saison c'est yacouba
ouattara vous à charge gerry boulet ciel
william howard se faire voler mon passé
ça fofana la deuxième saison c'est ganis
morand et est avec toi et isaiah et la
troisième saison de mémoire c'est
antoine haut à l'aise
doit rennes racines
et et je ne sais plus je ne stoppe la
tap a des airs de mensah dedans
maintenant je comprends ce jeune en
jeunes parce que ça concerne pas aussi
que les jeunes moins de 23 ans jeune
rookie américain j'ai eu austin ohlins
et terry tarder
gg prix en sortie de l'université
au piano lynch eut un avant parcours
après derrière parce qu'ils étaient
allés jusqu en euroligue il y est
toujours puisqu'il est à l'étoile rouge
cette année mais change de vêtements je
ne voyais pas ce faut être très modeste
parce que je pensais pas kostine serait
à ce niveau là sincèrement
et justement tu as parlé des prêts
comment ça se passe concrètement en fait
un club s'il est intéressé par un joueur
il fait appel à qui al'âge en club les
deux comment ça se passe comme ça c'est
un truc c'est vrai que le grand public
on ne sait pas du tout comment ça se
trame
peut-être julien
une récupérer ouais ça excusez moi je
pense que j'ai des problèmes avec te
ment super bowl pour le prêt déjà
bon moi je trouve ça très vertement dans
la même problématique que
jean-christophe à savoir qu' on va pas
saint-quentin récupérer les meilleurs
jeunes joueurs on essaye de se faire
prêter par les meilleurs centres de
formation donc et moi j'essaye toujours
d'en avoir un peut-être deux est en tout
cas vraiment un que je me fais prix que
j'essaye d'avoir sur un un rôle et un
espace de jeux où je vais vraiment
pouvoir lui donner d'une certaine
liberté parce que alors le prêt il faut
qu'il ya un accord effectivement des
trois parties du club de croix du
représentant du joueur et du club qui va
recevoir le prêt donc la façon dont ça
se passe la plupart du temps je tout le
monde est assez d'accord très souvent
l'agent de joueurs étaient ok parce
qu'il s'adresse permettre ça va
permettre à son jeune joueur d'avoir du
temps de jeu le club de bois parfois
avoir difficultés parce que le joueur
est parfois un peu limite c'était le cas
du bo besson est ce qu'on va le garder
pas le garder il est 10e peut avoir du
temps de jeu chez que tout le monde
n'était pas complètement ok à l'élan
chalon et
voilà par exemple pour cette année avec
nesta lydie fusil et le club d'orléans
ça ça roulait vers ce que tout le monde
était ok et tout le monde savait que ça
pouvait être le projet adéquat pour
qu'il passe un cap donc voilà ça se
passe comme ça après
moi quand j'ai un joueur en prêt
ça nous oblige
parce que bon moi je veux vraiment
quelqu'un qui a du potentiel
qui a dans l'idée c'est quand même un
petit puisse revenir derrière dans son
club de croix pour y avoir du temps de
jeu et
et nous on vraiment ont travaillé en
collaboration évidemment le travail avec
le joueur je te rejoins jean christophe
sur ce que tu disais tout à l'heure sur
le jeune joueur on l'est on les
accompagne pas simplement pour être des
joueurs de basket on les accompagne
aussi pour devenir les hommes parce
qu'on a la plupart du temps des gars
mais qui débute le monde professionnel
qui sont pour la première fois confronté
à toutes les problématiques
que ce que devient leur métier et de
travailler aussi avec des adultes et pas
simplement avec des garçons de leur âge
mais ça nous oblige aussi d'avoir des
travailler joueurs prêtés à avoir une
collaboration dont on collabore très
très très régulièrement avec avec
orléans cette saison avec l'élan chalon
année dernière avec les représentants
des joueurs pour qu'on est tous ensemble
on aille dans la même direction et qu'on
puisse aider le jeune joueur a progressé
tout au long de la saison avec
évidemment je le répète un espace voilà
donc là cette année les stades is you
sur le post ça fait deux années que je
prends des postes 2 qui ont une qualité
de scoring et je trouve que ça
correspond bien parce que quand ils ont
quand même un talent départ ils peuvent
on s'est vite
évolué en pro b et c à nous ensuite de
les aider à polir son talent et à le
mettre au service d'une équipe et du
niveau de jeu qui va être le leur sur la
scène du
hockey et sur justement sur ce que vous
avez une espèce de veille toute l'année
sur les performances ceux des jeunes
comment ça se passe vous avez un résout
vous contacter ça marche la
reconnaissance ça marche comment ces
agents qui vous contactent qui me disent
ah mais c'est un peu juste pas à trois
peut-être qu'on pourrait être prêté en
pro b
comment ça se passe un petit peu les
coulisses un sens rare et voilée
dévoiler les secrets des dieux bien sûr
mais comment comment ça se passe pour
vous tout au long de l'année par rapport
à ça
tu y es tu vas julien
baer encore c'est pas en fait je peux
pas quand je peux je vais vous parler de
deux ans mais je vous parlais de paris
basket parce que ces deux choses
complètement différentes
donin c'était c'était oui
ma connaissance du milieu espoir le
suivi des joueurs un petit peu aussi les
agents qui parce que t'as pas le temps
de voir tout le monde
et puis j'ai envie de te dire qu'à la
fin de la première année à denain a vu
que j'avais yak
raf et jerry quand tu fais une une bonne
première année avec des gamins c'est
plus facile la deuxième année j'ai envie
de te dire que la deuxième année on de
les confier un peu plus facilement ou
tout du moins à un blocus d'appel paris
basket ball c'est un peu différent parce
qu'on a eu on a créé un dès la première
saison a créé un département scouting et
donc on se coupe des joueurs
français et étrangers
dans le monde entier en français partout
de 13 à 33 ans et donc et donc veut j'ai
vraiment des personnes gées on a on a
une cellule scouting il ya à peu près 15
personnes dans le monde entier ces noix
brugmann un ancien coach professionnel
qui gère cette cellule et est donc on
est sur les terrains en permanence
l'uimm alerte dès qu'ils voient un gamin
intéressant et
moi je vais je vais souvent voir voir le
joueur jouer tu vois là on est déjà sur
les de la génération 2000 2007 et 2008
d'accor à bbb oui oui parce que parce
que ces voix là on a avait lancé notre
première génération qui étaient les 97
avec gauthier denis valentin chéri
voilà la deuxième génération c mylan
julian et ismaël et là on est déjà sur
la troisième génération avec pas comme
dadié maudira qui sont 2005 qui sont 11e
et 12e trous et on travaille maintenant
sur les générations d'après
julien peut-être oui alors à saint
quentin dans des styles de paris sera en
vente sur deux deux divisions
championnat espoir pour la nationale une
donc déjà un travail on essaye de
travailler un peu surtout de la saison
avec un staff et mes deux adjoints
on essaye sur le début c'est pas
toujours simple mais de se séparer un
petit peu les équipes mais même de façon
globale on est toujours prêt à rester en
veille sous ses deux divisions là et
puis ensuite on franchement c'est
énormément de
d'appel moi j'ai des
personnes qui je pense sont connaissent
très bien ces deux divisions donc tous
les ans j'appelle différentes personnes
je leur demande
les meilleurs joueurs quels sont les
joueurs potentiels que enfin et ça me
permet ensuite d'établir une sorte de
bas de classement mais de liste pour
voir les joueurs qui vont ensuite
correspondre au mois aux critères que
que j'ai décidé parce que selon les cas
par exemple cette saison a décidé de
donner sur les que
sur notre site postes extérieurs on en a
pris trois jeunes donc poster un poste
de poste 3 c'est trois gamins 20 ans
même pas donc voilà il fallait qu'à
partir monde avait décidé cela il
fallait que ya un bon équilibre sur les
qualités de chacun donc après on y va
par priorité à cette année ça s'est fait
moi je regarde aussi beaucoup la
nationalité parce que c'est une division
que fo très intéressante où il ya aussi
beaucoup de jeunes joueurs et donc cette
année j'ai été beaucoup cherché dans
cette division ce que j'ai trois joueurs
j'ai lunel nous document de 23 mai que
je me vois quand même 25 ans qui vient
de prendre chéruy et g j'ai lu calbuco
qu'il était arrangé et formé à challans
et j'ai et j'ai calé ligne politique qui
lui a évité par exemple à notre priorité
a essayé de recruter très très tôt en
provenance du havre et en fonction
ensuite de recrutement de calvin on a
été chercher les joueurs à côté et on
est on est en veille sur ses deux
divisions la
cdca intéressant ce que voulaient les
trois je les connais pour être passé
dans des clubs où il était notamment
messieurs yuko et donc tonton intérieur
l'achipel prendre sur l an dernier la
saq et je crois que le parcours de
lionel il est super intéressant parce
que un petit peu court à la sortie
parthenay entraînements avec nous mais
au final par jouer sur les divisions n2
n1 et s'aguerrit pour au final
aujourd'hui un joueur à joueur
intéressant de complément comme j ai
fait les voilà c'est parfois pas hésiter
à regarder à sortir un peu des deux à
faire des choix comme ça c'est toujours
intéressant exactement son parcours et
je trouve montre beaucoup d'intelligence
ça veut dire que dépensent
ils doivent jouer donc je pense qu'il
vaut mieux aller descendre d'une
division peut-être de deux divisions
aller jouer dans un contexte qui va lui
être favorable plutôt que de faire le
11e le 12e pendant deux trois quatre ans
quand on peut s'entraîner avec les
professionnels est joué en espoir c'est
intéressant
et là lionel ça montre bien parce que je
pense vraiment que s'il n'avait pas été
chez nous c'est déjà signer chez nous il
aurait signé ailleurs en province il est
mérité avoir sa place et il est encore
un jeune joueur c'est encore un jeune
joueur pour les intérieurs de toute
façon il faut que je pense un petit peu
plus de temps et donc il est jeune et
n'a que 26 ans je pense qu'il a
peut-être qu'on va demander l'avis d'un
coup bas il ya koba de 60 ans
moi je t'en parle ouais ça lui
on a eu une belle vie si de ton garage
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que cela fait
quand toi tu as et erreurs
responsabiliser au début de sa carrière
c'était un âge idéal de mémoire
qu'est-ce que comment tu as sorti savait
ce que c'était quelque chose qui était
compliqué à gérer ou pas
oui à l'époque vous m'entendez la toile
on est très bien
non oui à l'époque moi quand j'étais à
l'âge idéal au centre de formation
s'était montré mes recettes et joël
delaby et à l'époque les jeunes jouaient
pas du tout c'était très rare c'était
c'était
c'était un très gros problème je dirais
un gros problème qu'avait en france
j'étais très déçu par rapport à ça par
rapport aux jeunes qui jouent et c'était
vraiment à l'époque c'étaient des frères
piétrus qui est à pau il avait boris
diaw qui jouait un peu
mon époque 81 83 je dirais c'était
c'était c'était tout ce que moi à
l'époque j'étais à la dijon à ginel
dijon la première à néant l'espoir c'est
un peu difficile comme je ne devais pas
d'appeler la deuxième année s'est très
bien passé mais je faisais le banc mais
je m'entraîne à fond plus est la
troisième année je montre mes quasiment
tous les jours avec les pros mais j'ai
joué à peu près 10 secondes par match à
l'époque l'entraîneur c'était christine
gloutonne qui organisait souvent que les
américains et moi je pensais que et
quand j'étais mieux hdr il y avait un
très gros de jeunes bail avec karim
souchu et déjà il jouait pas beaucoup y
avait pas chez alice morin y avait mon
beau comptait y avait laurent cazalon
on avait quand même un très gros groupes
ce qui m'a déçu énormément c'est que ils
n'ont pas fait jouer les jeunes je pense
que si m'aurait fait jouer en pro je
serais jamais parti serait jamais parti
à l'université que jamais partie
money time ça s'est passé après mais
comme moi jamais donné la chance moi
j'ai toujours dit que de donner la
chance et après six mois derrière je
n'avais pas la prendre je ne suis pas au
niveau je comprends tout à fait tu mens
mais quand au niveau études et passe les
proies mon âme ont l'âge de 18 ans je
l'avais déjà dépassé beaucoup de pros je
ne citerai pas de noms je m'entraîne
tous les jours comme un malade je
pensais que j'avais au moins la chance
d'avoir une chance de montrer ce que
j'avais sur le terrain et à l'époque
entrant en 6e à jouer les jeunes et on
l'avait un très gros groupes de jeunes
en france on regarde la génération 89 83
même 84 et après et se demander pourquoi
les jeunes joueurs français partent à
l'étranger pourquoi les joueurs jeunes
français très fort parc à l'université
parce qu'en france on n'est pas notre
chance et ça j'étais c'était un très
gros couplet montfa l'unité souvent les
américains à l'époque c'était quoi
quatre américains peut-être par équipes
si je me trompe pas au moins
ce qui m'a fait plaisir à pons
[Musique]
berges dans ses bijoux qui lui qu'à six
élus bergeaud qui avait poussé à faire
jouer les jeunes qu'avait mais les deux
frères piétrus qu'avait mais boris diao
qu'avait mis artistes rentrent ils
avaient mais presque 400 jeunes et
derrière il a éprouvé deux
professionnels aux américains il a fait
quasiment une équipe française de jeunes
avec des jeunes joueurs et ça je pense
que ça s'est très bien passé avec des
bons joueurs et mon premier match idéal
je pense que l'âge idéal si on aurait
fait ça je pense que beaucoup de jeunes
proches restés en pro on a réfléchi
pense qu'on aura fait des belles choses
ce qui quand je regarde son papier karim
souchu djuro pas chez les marlins
joueurs pour williams lors joueur prend
laurent cazalon joueurs pros il y avait
quand même du monde et je pense que
l'erreur qu'ils ont fait à cette époque
ce n'est pas faire donner la confiance
aux jeunes et que c'était très difficile
donc moi sur ce sur ce projet là j'étais
vraiment déçu pendant des années et des
années et ça a changé un peu je dirais
ça a évolué un peu quand on est parti
parce que beaucoup de gens me
demandaient pourquoi tu restes pas je
peux pas rester en pro je joue cinq ou
dix secondes par match donc c'est pour
ça que j'ai tenté l'aventuré
universitaire et pour moi ça s'est très
bien passé j'ai parti à l'université en
junior college ils sont revenus à la gta
dans mon club formateur non c'est déjà
cela à l'époque qui m'a contacté il a
dit que si tu avais niveau charles v là
bas j'ai bas en trois mois d'après
sparks en italie que je pense que s'il
agit d amore donné ma chance en 2000 je
serai jamais partir universités je pense
très sèche je serais resté à la gta pour
un bon bout de temps comme à l'époque on
ne sait pas jouer les jeunes
donc je suis parti je partais tenter
l'aventuré ailleurs où on me respecte
donc on m'a donné ma chance et derrière
je pense que j'ai pas de regret je suis
très content du choix que j'ai fait
alors justement tu parles de tes
différentes expériences on a sur ce
plateau ont trimé romain jean christophe
qui vont coacher à l'étranger est-ce que
la mentalité dans
d'autres pays est différent par rapport
à ça ou risquent effectivement il ya eu
une évolution aussi beaucoup en france
parce que je pense que notamment en pro
b on voit pas mal de voir qu'ils ont été
prêtés cette année dans sa machine
chouba je pense à la clémence riches
office de steed tchicamboud
quel est votre point de vue sur ça en
fait finalement
je sais
on a plus d'une heure et demie
la fois qu'on a parlé de ça c'est à vous
une tribune à dohnany resté une heure
donc pas le temps
car il ya plusieurs questions dans ta
question il ya la question de l'étranger
il ya la question de la pro b je pense
que la pro b à est en train de récolter
les fruits de de tout le travail que les
coaches ont fait depuis depuis depuis
sept huit ans de mettre des jeunes sur
le terrain
et donc du coup je suis vraiment très
content de voir le il ya quand même
beaucoup beaucoup de gamins maintenant
qui beaucoup de clubs pros qui acceptent
de prêter langue ça c'est bien
et tant mieux
et c'est encore plus dur aujourd'hui de
faire jouer des jeunes en pro b que ça
ne l'était sur ma première saison à
demain donc je vous parle de 2014 2015
parce que à l'époque il faut se
rappeler qu'on avait que trois étrangers
en pro b aujourd'hui en a quatre et moi
si je devais me dit tu es à quelque
chose ce serait un retour un retour à 3
3 étrangers en pro b parce que
très souvent très souvent sur les trois
sur les quatre étrangers en est qui et
qui est pas toujours de grande valeur et
donc du coup ça peut permettre ça peut
permettre d'avoir peut-être un gamin en
plus secret quand vous avez que trois
étrangers les français coûte cher donc
en pro b on peut pas toujours les
attirer donc ça veut dire qu'à un moment
ou un autre il y aura plus de plus de
jeunes sur le terrain voilà un peu
comment arbitrage à 3
c'est un peu quand l'arbitrage à 3 j'ai
pas compris non c'est celui trop le
troisième le troisième on s'en rend
souvent compte sur les compacts
international et 3e mardis du trio est
pas toujours j'ai bien joué monsieur
je suis d'accord et je joker tu sur
l'étrange
écoute alors c'est compliqué d'en parler
parce que moi je suis partie avec harman
qui avait non non cette fille
de développer des jeunes et la chance
que j'ai eue quand j'étais avec hermann
c'est karmann m'a toujours dit un truc
que je garde en tête c'est que à partir
du moment où tu joues tu plomb seul
entraînement tu en a rien à [ __ ] de
savoir quel âge on tait joueurs n'en a
rien à [ __ ] de savoir quelle est leur
couleur de peau tu en a rien à [ __ ] de
savoir combien il gagne
tu t'occupes que était trop concilie si
les meilleurs jouent pas après c'est pas
aussi simple que çà et
là grosse difficulté aujourd'hui
c'est que un pro il est là pour
peut-être une année pour faire des stats
pour son contrat de l'année d'après et
quand il voit un jeune joueur
avoir du temps de jeu parfois ça peut
lui poser problème donc c'est je pense
que c'est ça souvent qu'il faut manager
voilà donc manager les égos par rapport
à l'achat ça c'est quelque chose qui
existe toujours en fait c'est à dire que
la liste mais rapport à un
potentiel temps de jeu c'est toujours
pareil faut
aimer ça c'est des choses que je sais
que moi dans le recrutement j'en parle
aux joueurs professionnels que je
recrute clair que quand ils sont avec
des jeunes joueurs je leur demande
d'être plus que des plus que des joueurs
lambda
voilà et la chance que j'ai aujourd'hui
et j'ai envie de vous dire c'est que sur
les joueurs qui ont un petit peu
d'expérience et qui accompagne mes
jeunes joueurs ont les signes sur des
années sur plusieurs années donc du coup
ça leur enlève le stress
d'éventuellement avoir à faire des
stades pour la saison d'après et ce qui
n'était pas le cas demain à l'époque
j'ai qu'on a on en est sûr sur toute
façon sur le constat c'est soit on fait
jouer dans ton tous les cas on fait
jouer les jeunes joueurs partent projet
soit ces projets de coach au départ kimi
si ça ça c'est un projet de club parce
que pour des raisons si économique à
terme c'est peut-être quelque chose de
rentable soit parce que c'est moins cher
soit parce que dans le cas d'une des
rares qui peut on peut récupérer des
fonds pour récupérer quelque chose si on
est reparti mais dans tous les cas il
faut qu'une volonté un projet de club
signalé joueurs sur plusieurs saisons
comme vous faites cesser du project web
aujourd'hui ce qui manque un petit peu
je trouve mais c'est mon avis perso
c'est très souvent les dirigeants
lillois sur deux cycles 6-8 mois un an
au delà de ça et quand on a la chance de
tomber dans les structures où on peut le
dire et faire un peu de pédagogie auprès
des gens ou avoir de diré ils vont dans
ce sens là c'est super intéressant parce
que ça permet de construire justement et
ça enlève eu vraiment de la pression
aux gars tu vois je respire tu vois
aujourd'hui on parle d'un joueur lambda
mais tu prends gauthier de neil arce
signé 4 1 chez nous la seule pression
qui la lui c'est de se mettre au niveau
de ladite bénite et de continuer à
progresser quoi parce qu'il est c'est
non point avec une clause de sortie ou
trois ans donc
d'où ces bonbons dans un profil de
joueur différent c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous le directeur sportif et le
choix de fineo jfl pour trois ans qu en
arrivant que soient les au cavalière
yanis et dont tu parlais tout à l'heure
et et jb maille et c'est aussi pour ça
qu'on va prolonger certains n'osent
étrangers sur deux saisons en fin de
saison dernière parce que quand tu as
des mecs qui sont sains équipe qui bosse
autant hôtes ont fidélisé autant
construire et c'est là où justement
ferrand saint palais mais clermont
clermont clairement là dessus tu gères
voilà je pense que les c'est compliqué
de signer des étrangers dès la première
année et une fille ans d'abord mais si
tu vois qu'au bout d'un an confiance
avec ça se passe bien il n'y a pas de
raison que y'a pas de raison que le bail
soit pas plus longue
justement soit tu es un petit peu évoqué
jean christophe sur le fait que dans
trouvailles comme en en retour justement
quand les consciences pourquoi des
jeunes comment on entoure quel profil en
sélectionne pour entourer justement des
genevois
après tout dépend des dépôts ce que tu
recrutes chez les jeunes mais
globalement j'ai toujours dit que
mes meilleures assistant coach c'était
mes joueurs cadres
parce que la nature humaine et elle est
faite comme ça
quand tu dis quelque chose à tes enfants
ils n'ont pas été écoutés parce que il
ya une forme
il ya un lien hiérarchique
voilà si un pain de ton enfant dit la
même chose que ce que tu viens de dire à
ton enfant il va les écouter
naturellement parce que c'est comme ça
que marche la nature et mène donc en
fait
souvent mes joueurs cadres sont sont mes
joueurs relais
souvent mes joueurs cadres sont les
joueurs relais et donc du coup ils
renforcent le message que j'essaye de
faire passer avec certains jeunes
joueurs parfois ça prend du temps et
donc derrière il ya tout un travail qu
il se passe des choses dans un vestiaire
il ya une vie dans un vestiaire et et si
tu as un relais comme ça dans le
vestiaire c'est toujours intéressant de
la même façon que
beaucoup du travail individuel qui a
réalisé est souvent un travail
individuel qui est réalisé avec un jeune
joueur est aussi un joueur expérimenté
et pas uniquement qu entre jeunes
joueurs donc je crois beaucoup à ça
après c'est pas toujours simple de
trouver ces joueurs là c'est pour ça que
j'essaye de les bâtir au paris basket
ball sert qu'en fait tu vois un joueur
comme dustin ce liban qui arrivait chez
nous comme orange dès
aujourd'hui après trois ans chez nous il
est passé dans une bulle un petit peu
plus haute c'est la façon dont je
construis mes équipes et donc du coup
lui il devient un relais important pour
moi parce qu'il est passé par ces étapes
là c'est marrant parce que tu vois de
dustin la première saison
s'est dit
j'ai été vraiment extrêmes c'est un des
joueurs depuis que je suis coach avec
lequel j'étais le plus difficile c'était
un cheval sauvage qui couraient dans
tous les sens du timing spacing
comprenez rien du tout il court et donc
quand on voit où trois ans la relation
qu'on a bâtie tu vois aujourd'hui
d'austin il ya un regard il ya un truc
il a compris c'est les choses des
conneries mais c'est quoi et donc il est
passé traverse et
il est passé à travers ce que ce que
vivent aujourd'hui pas comme didier mau
diawara et c'est marrant parce que c'est
des gamins de 16 ans qui sont inclus et
c'est souvent d'austin qui va les voir
donc tu as un relais gaillard un relais
fort là dessus voilà je crois beaucoup
en sort
pour la commune l'accompagnement des
jeunes je
lui dirai ce que ça se fasse pareil au
sqbb avec par exemple je sais pas avec
un benoît jd oui alors oui
ça sous ça se passe pas complètement
comme ça parce qu'on n'a pas beaucoup de
joueurs d'expérience et après benoît
lui très intéressant en tant que leader
par l'exemple
si c'est lui d'ailleurs aussi à de
narino semble n'y est pas très vocal par
contre l'idée c'est quand on les jeunes
joueurs d'ailleurs c'est des cons bâle
ii de toute la construction d' équipe
c'est d'avoir de ne jamais avoir de
joueurs qu'ils soient exactement dans le
même rôle et dans la même façon de jouer
donc là par exemple tu vois l'année
dernière hugo à côté de benoît sa fuite
est plutôt bien parce que l'on est on un
permettait le tir de l'autre et quand on
a un joueur comme hugo qui on a place et
à qui a besoin d'avoir le ballon
s'exprimer benoît lui peu joué 35
minutes tiré deux fois à son problème il
va faire d'autres choses il va amener
d'autres choses à l'équipe par contre
tout ce qui est le travail individuel et
l'accompagnement du jeune joueur là je
m'appuie sur mon staff on est trois et
on travaille vraiment ensemble pour que
le jeune joueur soit le mieux
accompagner possible et dans le
management aussi c'est important j'ai
besoin d'avoir des jeux des démos nombre
taf qui donne les informations qu'il
faut et puis pas trop si derrière parce
que la saison n'est pas un autre chose
confie elle est parfois il peut y avoir
des moments où le coach est dur avec les
joueurs et ce sont eux moi qui me
passent davantage les informations cette
année j'ai récupéré un joueur c'est à
dire en alzamora rtit entre lui vraiment
très très bien par contre dans cette
case et on va pouvoir l'utiliser
davantage dans le
dans l'aide et dans l'entourage et des
déchets de joueurs et le il commence
déjà très bien c'est vrai que c'est
précieux ces précieux pour un coach
parce que ce sont vraiment des garçons
qui ont déjà l'expérience du haut niveau
et qui savent que son os qu'on dit aux
joueurs que c'est bon pour eux donc ils
sont capables de relayer le message et
c'est fondamental je pense que ça a une
part très importante dans le fait que
que les jeunes progressent où environ là
durant la saison c'est comme disait jean
christophe tout à l'heure il faut que
d'autres que nous puisse passer le
message
est ce que yacouba tu as déjà fait ce
rôle là un peu du grand frère pour
accueillir les jeunes dans ta carrière
en soit la fin de ta carrière
est ce que c'est quelque chose qu'on t'a
demandé de faire explicitement
aggrave les avec
souleymane diakité ousmane camara avec
[Musique]
ce message là j'avais beaucoup plus
en tentant un peu moins y ont tenté un
petit peu loin
moyens mais qui continue
je prends ton peuple est ou pas n'ont
pas vraiment
non plus mais vas-y côtier ouais
au vcm comme je joue
un peu avec matthew jones qui s'était le
plus jeune de l'intrigué
plus qu'en france parce que l'italie
vraiment
alors qu'à des espoirs il me laissait
carrément des fois à venir montrer
gentil je m'entraînais avec eux
carrément de temps en temps
contre elle moi j'aime j'aime travailler
j'aime progresser j'aime travailler dans
les choses que
j'aimerais ajouter des choses à mon jeu
j'aime observer j'aime regarder donc
tomber coûts de l'ordre de nous
l'expérience n'est pas souvent que tu
vois un jour un billet un joueur pro
je faisais quand même les deux quand
même mais avant je m'entraînais que les
cadets je voudrais je m'entraînais avec
les espoirs et d'ailleurs je fais à
l'entraînement des pros tu dormais au
gymnase non
non parce que moi je comme j'ai dit j'ai
pas eu l'honneur d'avoir un pro qui
fasse ça pour moi et moi derrière
d'avoir cette opportunité de donner ça
aux jeunes vraiment ça m'a ça m'a attiré
on serait au coeur de vraiment leur
donner des choses que moi j'ai jamais eu
en fait
regarder un joueur
voit les matchs espoir j'aime bien me
j'aime bien
leur donner satisfaction et derrière ils
me regardent et j'essaye de essayé de
leur donner de mon max possible et sur
sa maman je compte beaucoup honneur avec
sa
relation qu'ils ont vraiment besoin de
vraiment besoin de ça d'avoir les
anciens joueurs pros
ont porté les choses que i
- suite à des tas des joueurs qu'ils
bros
longtemps et c'est de travailler sur la
nutrition sur ton stretch
sur sa génération et ça je dirais je
vais souvent donné en italie et là ce
que je fais maintenant aux états unis
ok
j'aimerais qu'on aborde maintenant le
point un petit peu est-ce que sur les
demandes des voix par rapport aux axes
de progression en entraînement est-ce
que quelques fois vous êtes un petit peu
en conflit sur les choses qu'il faut
travailler ou non pas du tout
bien sûr que oui encore eux
ce serait trop apprécié de 6 non
évidemment
bon moi je me sers beaucoup de la vidéo
individuellement
vraiment pas parce que le joueur peut
voir des choses pendant le match sentir
des chefs des choses à voir infinie
gouard une situation et puis bon sur la
vidéo quand on fait l'arrêt sur image ou
même quand on voit la situation en live
ça ment pas et là ça peut nous permettre
de travailler d'autres choses on n'est
pas toujours en accord l'année dernière
on a eu un vrai sujet avec hugo sur par
exemple
sur l'utilisation du flotteur parce que
tout à l'heure quand on en parlera il a
un bras la très longue distance il ya un
bras longue distance il a une capacité à
finir près du cercle et dans cet espace
là entre les deux
moi j'avais le sentiment qu'ils
pouvaient voir progresser et voilà ça a
été un sujet pour nous donc on la beauce
et après elle je pense vraiment que si
le joueur de façon
de plus globale on est là pour
accompagner les garçons on les forme pas
c'est notre capacité de travailler il
faut être hyper humble un bon coin à ça
donc on les accompagne on leur donne des
conseils il est prêt ni les peines pas
mais et on essaye aussi et surtout de
leur apprendre la rigueur du haut niveau
et devenir des hommes mais
c'est le joueur il n'a pas ils croient
pas en la consigne qui ne décroît pas
entre ce que tu as envie de faire
travailler le fera pas donc on n'est pas
toujours d'accord voilà après je me bats
pour essayer de d'être d'avoir les
meilleurs arguments possibles pour que
ça fonctionne il ya des choses sur
lesquelles je suis intransigeant et
d'autres sur lequel je suis moins tu
vois sur le flotteur bon ni a été j'ai
senti que bon là je vais regarder le
championnat australien cette saison pour
voir si ça passe mais bon il y en a eu
autant besoin de ça finalement la saison
passée il yad'autres jeudi à d'autres
aspects du jeu sur les ailes par contre
là ce sont pour moi des choses qui sont
complètement obligatoire pour aller vers
le haut niveau donc voilà je peux y
avoir différents exemples et là il faut
que le joueur si le joueur voit qu'il a
une difficulté ont passé un cap sur un
certain comme le dream sous pression
des clauzades défensif et n'importe quoi
là je pense que la presse ça peut être
utile et enfin on peut réussir à
pimenter pour pour réussir à faire
progresser quoique mais we will toujours
des sujets qui sont
ou sur lesquels on n'est pas d'accord ce
normal c'est normal et puis ça fait
partie de la formation nous on a une
vision de ce qu'on veut faire du joueur
et lui va avoir une vision différente
c'est logique retrouver il faut il faut
réussir à
j'appelle ça
ako construire il faut qu'on arrive à
construire quelque chose ensemble pour
que l'île puisse progresser et aider
l'équipe également ça c'est aussi un
sujet quand nous le quand je repense à
tous les jeunes joueurs qu'on peut avoir
de chacun de nos équipes on pouvait on
l'a déçu j'essaie aussi de leur faire
comprendre que c'est bien ils peuvent on
va vous donner des responsabilités lui
faut gagner et vous êtes maintenant dans
une équipe professionnelle etc puis en
espoirs ou en 1 ou le centre fédéral ou
alors n 1 si ça continue
la victoire défaite c'est pas si grave
l'an passé il faut comprendre ce que
vous faites a des répercussions sur le
score
sur le score est sûre métiers des gens
aussi que le soin les les coéquipiers ou
et coacher
les commerciaux enfin tu peux tu peux
faire toutes là toute la galerie d'art
est bien sûr tu vois ça a été un de ces
derniers on a commencé par deux défaites
de très peu et et ça a été une grosse
discussion avec plusieurs jeunes jeunes
de l'équipe à 0,2 de leur expliquer qu'
il y avait une exigence et qu' il
fallait maintenant passé un passé un cap
on était plus en espoirs c'était plus et
je me rends compte qu'on a le même
problème cc c'est humain c'est logique
il ya un temps d'adaptation j'ai la même
chose cette saison
donc il faut vite congrès savez ce que
tu dire on a un bon là tous côtés moi
j'ai connu une dessin par exemple avec
dijon ce que j'ai fait l'immense honneur
d'avoir travaillé dans les deux clubs
yacouba la gta et à des moments
différents et à gravelines j'étais coach
espoir quand il est venu en ami 13
éducateurs et
ouais j'ai connu une descente donc c'est
cet impact la bouche des banques j'ai
vraiment vécu mais les jeunes joueurs de
20 ans c'est pour de la m de
l'emmagasiner quoi sont pas conscients
des conséquences
sur christophe un petit peu le même
constat non pas du tout a paris sur la
façon de travailler et coupe nous en moi
paris m'a permis de mettre
de mettre en place tout ce que je ne
pouvais pas mettre en place à dos
d'homme ce cas demain on était 2 il y
avait le coach et l'assistance et
l'assistant il gérait les déplacements
et de la préparation physique
est pas exact où quoi donc mais ce qui
est souvent le quotidien d'un club de
pro b
malheureusement donc j'ai un grand staff
g13 personne dans le staff et donc du
coup j'ai pu vraiment créé
une cellule de
ski le développement donc ce que je
faisais donnant maintenant je le manager
est donc en fait ce qu'on fait nous dès
qu'on prend un jeune joueur on l'a fait
dès la pré saison avec valentin 1
gauthier avec juin 2000 à nice mais les
lavait pas cool bon je comprends des
vingt deux joueurs ont calé screening
nos jeunes joueurs
d'un point de vue prépa physique qu'en
fait on l'a on a créé des tests on a
créé un faux créé des têtes donc il faut
des joueurs
en fin de saison et tous les
cette photo nous permet d'établir à
[Musique]
un travail individuel de préparation
physique et six mois après un screening
avec
tout le travail qui a été fait pour voir
les évolutions les axes de travail qu'on
a fixés et on fait la même chose au
niveau basket ont fait la même chose au
niveau basket
est donc là là vous voyez on a
on à ismaël millan jeune kyle altman
qui à 83 ans pas comme dadié est maudit
hawara on commence la pré saison on
commence un premier cycle de travail
individuel jusqu'au mois de décembre et
ce cycle là ça correspond pour chaque
joueur à quatre séances de travail
individuel en plus des séances
collectives
donc globalement lundi au vendredi en
quatre séances en plus d'une heure et en
plus 45 minutes de musculation tous les
jours en plus des séances avec l'équipe
donc ça fait une grosse charge de
travail mais
c'est comme ça qu'on arrive à c'est
comme ça qu'on arrive à en tout cas
faire progresser nos joueurs
pour prendre un exemple concret ils se
mêlent la première saison
je lui ai appris à faire deux choses
j'ai appris
a compris
et je lui appris
ajout le rebond offensif les techniques
de comment le rebond offensif quatre
techniques pour reprendre des positions
pour verrouiller les positions des
techniques de brader
j'ai appris que sahil semaine et j'ai
dit si tu fais ça tu verras tu déjà
jeu va pouvoir jouer et on a fait tout
un travail au niveau du haut du corps la
deuxième saison à continuer ce travail
sonné le corps on a rajouté des choses
et après il ya tout le travail très
collectif les vidéos et machins et
saison à l'intersaison on a rajouté tout
un travail au niveau du bas du corps et
en fait on y va étape par étape on dit
souvent je pense que l'erreur que l'on
peut faire c'est de ces de vouloir
toucher un petit peu à tout et au final
on fait un petit peu de moyens partout
moi je préfère c'est quand c'est le
travail quand j'ai un jeune joueur je
sais que jeudi pour trois ans on sait le
travail est bien tiens là je vais je
vais ce qui va faire qu'il va pouvoir
être sur le terrain c'est ça et donc du
coup je vais là dedans et
après une fois qu'on a stabilisé un truc
on part sur le truc on est en tout cas
en tout cas
j'ai deux petites questions rapides
concours rien à voir l'une avec l'autre
mais la première je vous la pose à tous
les deux sur le travail indivise sur la
programmation plutôt point fort au plus
tôt points faibles dans la proche j'ai
toujours deux écoles par rapport à ça
exactions ils travaillent sur quoi sur
vos jeunes joueurs globalement
c'est une c'est une bonne question je
pars sur le
jeu par sur les sur les sur les points
forts en priorité pour je pense que s'il
est vraiment les gars on développe une
forte qualité
il peut aller vraiment un très haut
niveau
et on travaille quand même secondaires
on est quand même sur des choses parce
que parfois il ya vraiment des points
faibles qui sont trop fait pour évoluer
à un haut niveau donc qu'ils vont être
spécifiques notamment à la position du
joueur mais
on est vraiment dans l'idée de vouloir
progresser sur on a une base sur les
joueurs tu vois sur un type de joueur là
par exemple cette année en 1 heure de
jeu tiago qui est pas trés shooter repas
d'hier mais par contre qu'il ya vraiment
des qualités de vitesse d'agressivité
bas tournée là-dessus quoi on va essayer
évidemment le fait shooter beaucoup
parce que il faut qu'il progresse sur
cet aspect là parce que si la face à ça
sera difficile de passer le cap mais par
contre on est beaucoup plus sûr
développer ce qui fait de bien moi je
moi je pars de plus dans cette île est
large
je partage je partage je pense que plus
tu es fort sur ton point fort
puis tu vas avoir de l'énergie investir
sur des points de progrès alors moi je
parle jamais de point faible avec les
joueurs c'est de la sémantique mais je
parle pas on ne provoque
non mais c'est dans le mot faible il ya
une connotation je trouve très négative
non mais par exemple parlant et donc
donc oui oui oui je pense que provoque
un jeune joueur puisse évoluer
il faut renforcer sur son point fort et
après il aura plein d'énergie investir
sur sur exactement ses axes de
développement en tout cas c'est
ma deuxième question kelly à ça parce
que je vous la pose vous irez tomber
dans la mesure où pour y répondre à une
assurance que j'ai déjà vu ça
arrivé dans certains clubs parlent par
le passé plus ou moins récent avec
certains certains jeunes joueurs
dans quelle mesure il faut aussi tenir
compte de les visions de l'entourage et
des agents dans la programmation de
certaines choses par rapport aux deux
premiers joueurs est ce que c'est
quelque chose auquel nous avait déjà été
confronté et comment est ce que vous
gérez vous coach c'est une question de
mettre d'entrée leur entraîneur sur
savoir comment vous gérez cet aspect là
et dans quelles limites c'est ça plaît
ou pas être un facteur limitant
ça peut être un facteur limitant après
moi je pars du principe que moi je joue
la transparence dès le départ ça veut
dire que sur le recrutement on a
vraiment une grande collaboration est
une vraie discussion sur ce qu'on veut
faire ensemble et ça passe évidemment
avec avec le représentant du joueur on
peut pas faire sans aujourd'hui sont
partie intégrante
des projets des projets de carrière et
ce qu'il faut dès le départ c'est savoir
ce qu'on peut faire ensemble et qu'on
surtout qui ait pas d'erreur et les cinq
mois déjà là il ya des projets que j'ai
pas fait parce que je je je je je
voulais pas aller dans la même direction
le joueur ou son représentant ne voulait
pas la même chose après
durant la saison
quand on à
moi je collabore mais assez peu ça veut
dire que l'on rend parfois
des comptes quelques coups de fil mais
je veux pas en fait moi trop je veux pas
appelé pour me plaindre vont pas non
plus qu'on vient de m'appeler pour me
dire ouais mais ça va pas on fait des
points réguliers que ça se passe bien
que ça se passera bien puisque de toute
façon moi je considère qu'ils font
partie de la
du projet après c'est chacun son rôle et
quand ça c'est bien expliqué qu'on a des
gens intelligents
ça se passe bien ça se passe bien c'est
chaque c'est chacun son rôle le jeune
joueur il a aussi besoin d'avoir des
conseils extérieurs il a besoin d'avoir
un représentant 1 h en
moi partir à part tout le monde ça reste
dans le
voilà tu te tuer ton joueur dans sa
carrière
tu viens voir les matches parfois on en
parle ensemble et par contre après sur
tout ce qui est des aspects techniques
de terrain c'est entre le joueur le
coach ça se passe quoi est d'ailleurs
l'aps que j'ai eues on a pas de
discussion
voilà on est davantage mois avec l'agent
du joueur je suis davantage sur le
comportement l'éthique de travail les
attitudes après le temps de jeu un mois
je dois par exemple ce qui me fait ne
pas aller dans des projets parfois c'est
quand un agent me dis il faut qu'ils
jouent en 25 minutes bah je sais pas
comment je fais ça parce que même quand
l'arbitré lève la balle entre deux je
sais pas combien de joueurs combien de
temps dont je veux des joueurs donc
c'est pour moi c'est inconcevable donc
s'il doit jouer 36 jours à 36 joue pas
on est je suis un peu dans le même cas
que jc sous sa deuxième saison a donné
quand tu fais une première saison tout à
fait jouer des jeunes joueurs
maintenant les gens savent que si ça
fonctionne si des jeunes joueurs
méritent de jouer ils vont jouer s'il ya
un problème de temps je vois pas ce que
le coach attend en ligne j'adorerais -
mais par contre il faut répondre à
l'exigence donc il faut que y est aussi
une relation qui soit saine bois entre
tous les tous les acteurs
c'est mon point de vue il s'est parfois
pas simple
je crois que tu as répondu à vie tous au
quotidien
le problème c'est que j'ai l'impression
parfois que et
ils sont tous le nous le nouveau duc a
beau fixe avec un luke adam site chirac
un tony parker donc c'est de la
pédagogie il faut l'expliquer calmement
aux agences pour expliquer que parfois
joué que 15 minutes c'est déjà pas mal
qu'ils voient
et
dans l'ensemble ça se passe bien j'ai
envie de te dire que dans l'ensemble ça
se passe ça se passe bien après faut
hausser le ton qu'il faut c'est le temps
et voilà c'est tout quand quand on me
casse je suis plutôt conciliant je te
paye mais quand on gastro les couilles
c'est
une folie voilà donc je pense que tant
qu'on joue le jeu et
tu vois je alors peut-être à la
différence je garantis aucun temps de
jeu à personne en revanche
je garantis un temps le jeu quand même
je garantis un temps de jeu aux jeunes
de
se dire que moi ils savent ils savent
deux choses les jeunes joueurs ils
savent que
grosso modo autant que chez nous ils
auront à minima 15 minutes de grande
gueule
voilà que tu vas me l'admr beach et la
première saison on l'a pris pour être
des mômes et il a joué 12 une moyenne de
la première saison ils savent grosso
modo quand ils ont entre 10 et 15
minutes sauf problème de comportement
là je parle que basket
et
est par contre après j'ai pas de limite
ça j'ai pas de limite sur le temps de
jeu s'ils sont bons coins j'ai pas de
limite ça après c'est la guerre quoi
c'est mais c'est ça que j'aime bien
c'est qu'à l'entraînement il pousse il
pousse aussi ce qu'on sait on sait tous
que nos étrangers parfois ou de joie un
peu plus anciens temps en temps les
arrive
voilà je vois par exemple cette année
gérard yann boatwright dans un temps il
alors on loïc gendre et directement sur
votre ait c'est vrai que
s'il met tout de suite quoi parce que
sinon ils passent pas le milieu de
terrain donc donc bon ça se gère les
attends j'ai envie de te dire ça se gère
mais la seule chose que je voulais dire
moi c'est qu'il fonctionne c'était très
con ce que je veux dire et je peux pas
l'expliquer mais en fait moi je suis
fonctionne au crash
alors qu'en fait
quand je vois un joueur un jeune joueur
j'ai le crush coup j'ai pas le crush
tient que je sais que je peux pas vous
l'expliquer un cercle
à avoir ou est-ce que je peux l'emmener
et dans ces cas là ça veut dire j'ai un
crunch et givet soit j'y arrive pas et
parfois il peut avoir un gros potentiel
et je passe à côté mais si je vois pas
la projection du gamin à m + 2 ou mp3
jeu content et j'ai accès à côté
certains joueurs est clairement jeu et
je suis passé à côté d'eux à côté de
joueurs je suis passé à côté de joueurs
parce que je voyais pas tu vois et c'est
tout à ton honneur je viens moi moi hugo
des songes et jamais le crush etc il va
faire il sera peut-être drafté à la fin
de l'année et b mais je sais pas il ya
un truc chez j'ai pas eu ce truc là quoi
voilà alors c'est comme avec une
gonzesse plus le talent roche
alors encore celle à moi c'est comme ça
voilà je suis pas vous l'expliquer c'est
mon oeil
dans l'évaluation il ya une partie non
rationnel façon
dont clermont
tunis yeux je vous propose deux concerts
être là pour cette discussion on va
passer à la deuxième partie on va en
profiter pour remercier yacouba d'être
passé
yak merci beaucoup ainsi la prochaine
fois si tu es un bureau c'est encore
mieux
en tout cas c'était sympa merci beaucoup
c'est encore bon soit il à l'époque
salut
et puis on va passer à la deuxième
partie on va donc parler des prospects
quatre procès et on va commencer par
ceux du paris basket ball parce qu'il
faut bien dire paris basket ball je
crois avec on accueillait alors sur sms
en pl d'émissions télé il vaut mieux
dire pareil basketball
des deux pouvant recevoir à l'âme pour
parler à et pierre qui arrive
pour parler de ces quatre positif c'est
qu'on pourrait retrouver dès l'année
prochaine à la draft
halal on va commencer par toi avec les
prospects parisien ismaël kamagaté mines
barbiche nous sommes tout y est déjà bon
fort on suppose
que je commence à marquer par milano par
deux je sais que tu veux
bah je commençais par mahmoud darwich
parce que c'est celui que
j'ai le plus vu cet été dans début
d'année parce que il ya le contexte
paris basket mais aussi du contexte
euros équipes de france de jeunes oui on
a fait l'euro u20 l'eurochallenge
argument je crois que c'était un joueur
géorgie en géorgie où il était
franchement le est le meilleur attaquant
du un des meilleurs attaquants du
tournoi
l'équipe de france le leader et après
j'ai pu voir en live
contre les contre berlin et contre milan
début septembre à la halle carpentier où
il sortait du banc et ou franchement moi
j'ai vu début dé la vraie progression
chez lui à droite c'est forcément c'est
un bon attaquant un joueur qui peut s'y
trouve pas ses dribbles et shooter donc
il peut faire les trois choses doivent
faire le beau l'avenir il a un bon tir
en sorte iddri il a une bonne vision et
j'ai trouvé ce que qu'en fait il avait
de plus en plus
cette envie d'aller vers le cercle
pas de refus de contact pas de peur à
aller aller se se friter avec les grands
les grandes heures sera après les nra
l'un était pas l'équipe qui avait le
plus de grands le milan non plus mais
quand même cédé équipe type et euroligue
il arrêter je trouve offensivement très
très très à l'aise donc je pense que je
sais pas si c'est un pro 6 est un profil
et de billets parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
droits de garde combos comme ça aux
états unis on a énormément ils savent
très bien les former mais par contre je
pense que c'est un très très bon genre
un professionnel et racle qui craquent
la rotation du paris basket encore un
garde de la génération 2001 et son y en
a énormément je trouve que là il a une
progression linéaire de deux mois en
mois et s'est passé j'étais très très
très très positivement surpris en fait
parce que tu de france u18 je crois que
c'était en grèce il ya deux ans il était
derrière
cruzol gauzins il voit pas il voit pas
trop et en plus qui les analyse et
maledon n'était pas là la seule
génération 2001 il est hyper profonde et
l'aï avec l'euro u20 il a eu la chance
d'avoir un peu l'été de l'équipe il
salua fait prendre confiance et a été
très bon dans les bouts de matches
importants et là il a sa place dans une
rotation de 1re division donc c'est
super encourageant ce weed comment tu te
décrire et pour un joueur qui pourront
quelqu'un qui l'a jamais vu qui l'a
jamais vu jouer quelques elle voir
séquelles bottes qui est l'histoire
aurait toutefois améliorée on va dire
pas les points fait que j'ai bien
compris les gens qui s'appellent pas
dire qu'elles
sont poste j'ai un peu du mal à définir
les poches excuse son rôle son rôle
c'est plus simple porteur de balle
j'aurais aimé avoir le ballon moment
pour pour créer je trouve que c'est un
bon passeur c'est vraiment et il a un
bon oeil il peut jouer dupliquer
neurones il peut initier un peu de
l'attaqué la défense je crois qu'il a un
mètre 96 a été un mètre 95 96 donc s'il
prend un peu de coffre et qui se
développe un peu plus musculairement je
pense qu'il pourrait défendre les 1 2
donc
ça peut être comme ça que je le vois
c'est un four chaud torse à ce que les
américains prennent à un bac schumaker
il met des tirs assez compliqué c'est
messi je pense qu'il a énormément de
talent ou de surchauffe vrai vrai moi
on va donner la parole à jean christophe
on va juste rappeler que mylène barbie
chilien le fils devienne bar beach qui
était lui même joueur en pro qui passait
notamment aux véhicules et
2002-2004 de croix de mémoire
qu est-ce qu qu'est ce que tu penses de
tout joueur et de sa façon de d'éclore
au niveau sur christophe
cauet coup tu me donnes moi c'est un
crush que j'ai depuis longtemps est ce
que je les ai connus à 12 ans il est
venu s'entraîner avec denain quand il
avait 14 ans tu dois donc me millan il a
fallu d'abord stabiliser mylan c'est
peut-être des 3 juin à ismaël celui dont
je suis le plus fier parce que c'est
celui sur lesquels beaucoup de monde
avait quand même des doutes tu l'a
souligné alan il passait derrière un
paquet de joueurs il a fallu d'abord
stabiliser son corps alors qu'il fallait
dû prendre mylan fallait qu'il prenne du
muscle et il a pris il a pris 2,9 kilos
de muscles en deux ans et demi qu'on
donc tu sens tu sens que maintenant
aujourd'hui voilà comme tu l'as dit il
faut aller au contact qui résistent sur
les un contre un il a appris à défendre
en fonction de sa taille parce que c'est
ça aussi la particularité du basket
français c'est que millan aujourd'hui il
serait turcs allemands
grecs italiens
vitalien il serait au fenerbahçe j'y
serai au hisserait au pana où ils
seraient au bailleur parce que tous les
arrières de ces deux de ces équipes là
ils font 1 96 97 alors que nous on est
dans des divisions ou les arrières sa
williams tous les week-ends ils jouent
des gars qui font entre entre 7 et 12 cm
de moins que lui donc faut quand même
les tenir mylan
aujourd'hui il me fait beaucoup penser à
langnau
parce que en fait c'est quelqu'un qui a
un sens du basket incroyable il a il a
un instinct pour ce jeu très fort comme
souvent des des fils de coach et il est
comme non à la même époque il est
d'abord attiré pour scorer avant 2 avant
de passer la balle et je pense que tout
le travail qu'on a à faire avec mille
années tu vois cette année c'est au delà
du travail et à mon idole c'est de
trouver un équilibre entre ces deux
choses
c'est le gros c'est le gros le plus gros
axes de progrès 2001 de cette année
c'est que parfois il en fait trop et
alors qu'il ya des jours ouverts et ils
continuent d'avoir cette agressivité là
où il prend il prend le tir
et la difficulté s'il faut pas casser ça
non plus parce que comme tu l'as dit
très justement il est capable de mettre
des tirs qui viennent de ces dix mois le
dow il ya dix ans à qui on reprochait
mais joue d'abord pour ses par bonheur
il joue d'abord pour lui je pense que
c'est tout un équilibre que bill and va
devoir trouver et c'est le gros axes de
travail que l'on va on commence la
semaine prochaine avec lui avec kyle
altman qui a un peu le même problème et
avec gauthier qui aussi a un peu le même
problème parce que lui parfois il est un
peu trop tiens voilà mais pour pour
revenir pour finir mylan je dois
aujourd'hui je pensais que ceiling le
plafond s'étaient c'était l'euroligue
mais aujourd'hui j'en vois je suis pas
sûr de sarran tu fais quand tu vois
sergio rodriguez qui est allé en nba à
25 ans c'est quoi la différence entre un
mille années un sergio rodriguez et des
mines m il vient d'avoir 20 ans
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que sera millan
dans cinq ans
je ne peux pas te dire peut-être que ça
sera un bon joueur de betclic et lead
peut-être ça sans un joueur d'euroligue
peut-être sincèrement
je ne sais pas il n'y a pas de pour moi
ya pas deux il n'y a pas de limite à
milan l'instance générale
jb je peux me permettre 5 secondes il ya
un truc intéressant je trouve que
lorsque tu expliques sur la construction
des mecs je pense que c'est aussi tu
tues tu parlais tout à l'heure et julien
également de construire des individus
pas seulement de construire des joueurs
et il ya aussi une question je pense
dans la progression dans le fait que les
joueurs les jeunes joueurs puissent
accepter que il ya d'autres choses à
développer c'est lié aussi à la
construction de la personne c'est à dire
que c'est celle identité propre comment
est-ce que lui va comprendre qu' il va
exister à développer en ne faisant pas
que mettre des points et en créant par
les autres parce qu'il sait le faire et
c'est là où l'accompagnement pour moi
c'est le mot qu'utilisent julien tout à
l'heure où on forme pas des joueurs on
les accompagne c'est là où je trouve que
c'est très intéressant parce que c'est
faire prendre conscience aux gens dans
leurs constructions perso que ouvrir un
petit peu là les eaux hier les fenêtres
que vous voulez puis ni comprendre que
mme en rajoutant des petits éléments on
peut aussi devenir meilleur sur tous les
aspects
juillac on est coach adverse par rapport
à un milliard beach qu'est ce qu'on
demande at il voit en défense
la particularité
est dernière avec le paris basket ball
qu'on les a joués trois fois en
septembre en décembre et en mars et tu
peux pas faire un footing à chaque fois
des garçons qui ont vraiment progressé
de façon assez fulgurante à chaque étape
je pense par exemple à jouer à l'année
dernière quand on se joue en septembre
on peut faire une impasse sur le tir en
mars un peu plus du tout la faire par
exemple
est sûre
et sur millan j'ai le souvenir qu'on
était davantage sur la défense duty en
septembre et que en mars on avait un
joueur beaucoup plus complet face à nous
quoi donc
moi je vous trouve vraiment intéressant
cette progression et puis cette
capacitéà alors ça va aussi avec le
projet global du club et cette stabilité
qui est vraiment fondamental je pense
pour que les jeunes puissent évoluer je
trouve que mill and bar beach est un
jeune joueur et un jeune homme surtout
qu'ils qui ce qui se
dit ici ils se dévoilent vas tu vois au
fur et à mesure j'ai l'impression qu'il
est de moins en moins timide et pour moi
je trouve que vraiment il a une capacité
balle en main vraiment intéressante
ajouté je trouve qui chute libre et puis
c'est un garçon capable cacao si les
shoots à deux points à 3 points catch
and shoot et n'hésite pas et il avait un
des jeux portera développement à faire
sur mais ça va avec ce que disait jean
christophe sur
le fait de jouer des joueurs qui sont
beaucoup plus sinon qu'il avait quelques
difficultés parfois sur la pression
défensive mais vraiment c'est
intéressant
sur sur ce cas précis c'est vrai que
ce qui est génial c'est qu'au départ
tout le monde y croyez pas vraiment et
que aujourd'hui il a 20 ans il joue en
betclic élite il va avoir des
responsabilités
il est là et il a des pourcentages la
jeter un oeil du coup j'ai regardé un
tout petit peu contre
royan sondages aux lancers-francs là il
comprend pas ce qui lui arrive et voilà
voilà voilà voilà mais moi j'ai rien un
petit peu contre cholet mais bon sinon
tu vois ça veut dire que tu voies
notamment à deux points où il ya 68 % il
choisit bien ses dires par donc donc
c'est
très intéressant c'est très bien mais
les lanciers ça va venir du tout sinon
je sais bien que je suis
sur 12 lancers ça va aller
enfin si philippon j'ai jamais été comme
ça comme quoi elle est lancée c'est
aussi la tête mais c'est avant tout cela
pour moi faty tout se dire laisser
avancer que ça un nano machines
directement sur les mannequins la gaieté
mais moi en fait je que j'aime bien je
trouve que les trajectoires sont il ya
de la similitude entre les deux parce
que ces deux joueurs qui dans les années
précédentes avaient des entre guillemets
projet devant eux quand il fait part
d'aucune équipe de france de jeunes où
je conviens et qui l' ont une
progression je trouve depuis quelques
mois très intéressante je pense aussi
parce qu'en fait ils ont joué beaucoup
et jouer à cet âge là c'est là mais le
meilleur moyen de progresser
camani semaine kamagaté donc c'est un
poste 5 pour moi stricto sensu c'est
seulement un poste 5
1 raymond runner comme je les aime comme
je lé draft au 2ème tour parce que c'est
un joueur qui
ci comprend aussi on arrive à lui faire
répéter deux trois aspects du jeu
offensif ou défensif sera très très bien
les faire sur une quinzaine de minutes
même 20 minutes et je pense pour aller
faire à terme dans une rotation et demi
et je pense en tant que pivot backup en
guise donc cette année c'est le concept
pivot titulaire du paris basket il a
aussi fait l'euro u20 en géorgie
barbie che et kamagaté était pour moi
les deux meilleurs joueurs de l'équipe
avec peut-être hugo benitez
qui aussi d'ailleurs et un autre garde
de la génération 2000 pour montrer à
quel point elle est extrêmement profonds
qui prend dé minute en betclic élite
aujourd'hui
c'est ça donc
kamagaté poste 5 moi ce que je veux
vraiment qu'ils travaillent plus c'est
sa protection de cercle alors elle est
bonne elle et
tous m'ont parlé de ses premiers plans
10 bénite parce que il ya eu la stat des
neuf compte je crois dans ce prix là moi
je veux juste qu'il le faut qu'ils
sachent nombre mort d'un petit peu moins
sur les feintes et qu'ils puissent
défendre différemment c'est à dire en
gros j'aimerais bien qu'ils puissent
défendre à la fois en drop et s'il ya
une situation switch antique erreur
c'est beaucoup lui demandez pas ce que
c'est un poste 5 qui est pas loin des 2
10 mais ça peut être une carte d'entrée
supplémentaire pour la nba après ça
reste un très bon athlète il a la tête
au cercle iny j'ai trouvé quelque chose
très sous côtés pour l'avoir vu en vrai
contre milan et berlin a été parce je
trouve qu'il a une bonne qualité de
passe sur les renversements quand par
exemple on lui dire qu'il pose l'écran
et qu'ensuite on lui demande de
problèmes décision en leur donnant la
balle ils purent relais aller vers le
cercle finir mais il peut aussi renversé
dans les coins pour les shooteurs j'ai
trouvé ça très intéressant et important
pour un pivot moderne et puis il reste
ça reste un sport jeune qui joue
titulaire dans une équipe
professionnelle donc c'est super
intéressant après gilles gibaud juste
rajouté tu me disent tu es d'accord ou
pas moi j'aime assez bien sa mécanique
de tir déjà où l'on sait francs déjà il
ya 70% en effet de mettre 10 c'est quand
même déjà vraiment bien vraiment
intéressant et
book donc voilà je jean-christophe
ismaël kamagaté un croche pied je
suppose de ouf
ouais un crj office mels et j'ai fait
des pieds et des mains pour pour l'avoir
d'orléans
écoute isma c'est un rayon de soleil
séisme à chaque entraînement c'est comme
il me ramène à
mes années mais à may hamm et des
primaires où tu as 15 minutes pour jouer
au basket entre deux classes est élu il
est comme ça quoi en fait il vient pas à
l'entraînement il vient jouer au basket
lui comme s'il était en 30 rands entre
deux cours il il s'en fout de ce qui se
passe autour de lui de la hype du machin
du truc
je ne partage pas trop ton avis à la
charge partagée je partage pas je ismaël
depuis le début de la saison sur défunte
il a souhaité une fois sur tous les
matches
ok moi je parle vraiment ce que j'ai pu
voir en live à berlin et ils sont très
très tôt ils sont très très pas ce
combat parce qu'on leur a pris en
revanche si rim protecteur il a besoin
de travailler une chose et aujourd'hui
j'arrive pas on arrive pas on est bloqué
depuis un an là dessus c'est qu'il est
c'est un très bon contreur avec la main
droite mais il a beaucoup de mal à
contrer avec la main gauche
alors c'est peut-être mon exigence qui
est trop élevé rudy gobert y arrive pas
capella y arrivent pas ils comptent tous
avec la même main je pense que tu peux
arriver à contrer dès demain parce que
du coup
quant à quentin un arrière par sur sa
part sur sa main droite
il se mêle il a tendance à aller avec la
main intérieur donc la main droite et
donc à pouvoir faire faute alors que
steve avec la main gauche mais c'est une
mécanique d'appui qu'on n'arrive pas à
les faire passer du rang dans l'épreuve
entre le chat je pense enfin on
travaille là dessus le seul qui arrivent
naturellement à le faire regardez le
regarder le c'est victor wang manière à
lui le le fais naturellement dès demain
c'est incroyable et pour l'instant
j'arrive pas à faire passer le cap là
dessus à izmir ils se mêlent tu vois
cette année
un des gros son axe de travail c'est
qu'on veut le faire jouer facebook parce
que c'est pas un joueur de pau stocks
donc là où travaillent de fait les
derniers on l'a fait travailler sur avec
les avec les garde pour le développement
du bol en ligne là cette année on le
fait travailler sur tous les mouvements
fait seul je sais pas si vous regardez
juan juan yahya yahya il commence à
driver face au panier comment se prend
des tirs à 4 5
et on note on a tout un travail autour
du tir aussi à développer sur ismaël tu
vois aujourd'hui se mêlent-ils à hilla
il avec l'a7 sentir à faire tous les
jours à troyes il ya deux points
ils se mêlent sera pas un gag ça sera un
stretch paille comme on en fait en nba
aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui l'idée avec
qui se mêlent peut-être on n'y arrivera
pas c'est d'essayer d'en faire un effort
soit là parce qu'on pense vraiment
qu'aujourd'hui il allait il a le talent
il en est à londres pour pour y arriver
pour finir sur isma je pense que la plus
grosse limite 10 mai le séisme elle
c'est la première fois de ma carrière
que je fais faire des pompes à un joueur
parce qu'il refuse de prendre un tir aux
sabres en général quand ils sont ouverts
et les prennent les tirs ismaël et il a
et parfois il est encore en train
d'hésiter tu vois en fin d'entraînement
thaler il ya ka locklyn kyla engueuler
mais qui lui a dit m'attend je défendrai
pas sur toi j'étais à 5 mètres pour quoi
tu te rends pas le tir alors qu'il était
sur les baux des lancers francs mais je
pense que ismail a pas encore réalisé le
potentiel qu'il a donc en fait c'est sa
limite pour l'instant et je pense que le
jour où il va réaliser ça
ça va être
voilà tu as aimé mais ils se mêlent le
10 mai les vous rendez enfin je pense
que ce n'est pas contre mais à après le
match contre roanne il était tout gênée
d'avoir fait un bon match
celle ci ouvre mais ce n'est que c'est
ce qu'il sait ce qu'il est donc mais
c'est un qu'il faille se mêlent c16 ils
étaient tous comme ça après de l'e3 en
juin et mylan c'est aussi un kiffe mais
ils sont pas toujours tous comme ça
malheureuse pierre choix que tu connais
ajouté en introduction de la semaine
ouais je voulais savoir s'il y avait eu
un travail particulier cet été où depuis
la fin de la saison dernière sur la
mobilité sur l'agilité j'ai dans le
match contre rennes j'ai l'impression de
voir
joueur qui est beaucoup plus fort que
l'année dernière sur ses déplacements
avec
balle en main et aussi contourner les
adversaires
n'ont pas cet été il ya eu juste un
travail spécifique et ce comme il l'a
fait la compagnie 20
il a fallu louer un petit peu de repos
non on a juste fait un travail de
un travail de près par physique sur le
bas du corps en trois semaines il n'a
pas touché un ballon il a il a fait un
travail énorme sur le bas du corps de
squat de renforcement il a pris 5 cm de
diamètre de mollet
donc parce que mars est un travail ne
faut pas faire de basket un peu en ce
temps là parce que c'est tellement
sollicitant et énergivore non je pense
que c'est en fait le sait le décalage
que tu peux que l'on a entre ce que tu
arrives à faire à l'entraînement et ce
que tu arrives à produire en match en
règle générale ta ta ta ta toujours un
délai ça se passe c'est pas parce qu'ils
le font à l'entraînement qu'ils vont le
faire au match voilà tu rêves johan
l'année dernière
décembre janvier février il était
inarrêtable à l'entraînement mais quand
je les inarrêtables même nobel arrivait
pas l'arrêter et à partir du mois de
mars
début avril
on a commencé à voir ça mais il ya eu
deux mois d'écart pendant pas et pendant
ces deux mois là en match ça se passait
pas donc je pense que c'est juste les
temps de digestion en fait tu sais c'est
le les temps de le remettre dans le jeu
et c'est
julien qu'est ce qu'on disait à un ryan
rose pour stopper is my game kamagaté
pardon
ferme les yeux
non mais
sans déconner par contre spécifiquement
c'était le type de joueur qui contre
lequel x men kamagaté avait un peu de
difficultés parce que ils l'ont donc
sous les 3 mois ils se mêlent kamagaté
je les ai vus vraiment parfois même
stratosphérique je me souviens d'un
match à quimper la brb offensif c'est
absolument phénoménale et contre nous
ils je vous fais que ça a été une
constante je pense qu'il a été en
difficulté contre un certain type de
joueur intérieur qui le repoussait
tu vois qui travaillait au sol et du
coup ils étaient souvent ils reculaient
et hiberner un petit peu de je pense que
sa capacité à dominer donc
je pense que en l'occurrence l'exemple
de rien on ne s'est pas le bon exemple
facile il l'a vraiment merdé mais ça
n'empêche pas que leur moi c'est bien
parce que j -c répondu à la question est
ce que quand on les a joués il
travaillait énormément sur
l'échauffement très tôt à la salle sur
le tir extérieur avec avec bienvenus
donc voila c'était ma question date ça
c'est plutôt que te dire ce que j'en
pense j'aime introduit avec l'espoir
agissez sur le développement du tiers
est sûr également les développements d
attraper sur les charolles tu vois pas
ce que ce que je veux dire quoi est ce
que vous êtes un aspect que vous
travaillez avec lui est ce que sous les
pick and roll il est capable d'attraper
le ballon plutôt de de finir peut-être
un relais sur des passes ou est ce que
c'est quelque chose qui viendra prêter
non non c'est fait il des choses c'est
tous les axes de progrès de cette année
qu'on a déjà mis en place sur la
deuxième partie de saison mais très
clairement aujourd'hui saler les axes de
progrès disney qui se mêlent est
quelqu'un qui ne il n'aime pas jouer des
post up il est dans l'effacement sur le
post hoc d'ailleurs tu en parles et
pierre quand il a dû contourner le
joueur de roanne il a fait le tour en
dribbles il aime pas ils se mêlent ils
n'aiment pas le contact et c'est pour ça
crosms ils l'embêtaient énormément parce
que des joueurs comme ça qu'ils le
voient qu'ils impactent un petit peu oui
la main trop trop quoi et donc du coup
on est parti sur tout ce travail de
développement fait seube d'attraper des
ballons short corner de se mettre tout
de suite face au cercle et là dessus
comme il a une vraie mobilité et de pied
mais qui est pas dû à notre travail
c'est qu'en fait il vient du football
bien de police mais il est il était
footballeur jusqu'à l'âge de 14 ans et
comme il a pris 15 cm peut plus jouer au
football quoi donc mais il ya tout un
travail qui est mis en place aujourd'hui
avec qui se mêlent tous les jours c'est
bienvenu qui est responsable de ce
travail là sur le travail de d'attraper
faith alors il ya toute une gamme toute
une gamme de fondamentaux individuels il
ya toute une gamme de différents tirs
qu'on veut faire prendre à ismaël aussi
en catch and shoot en dribbles en sur
les rôles feinte de passe tirer toutes
ces choses là toutes ces choses là qu'on
essaye de développer chez lui pour que
ce soit à la fin de l'année un joueur
jour un peu plus complet
ont enchaîné sur hugo de bessan alors
les gobelets sont ces c'est de voir qu'à
exploser dernière à saint quentin
donc il était en provenance de l'élan
chalon lui c'est un du sud si je dis pas
de bêtises c'est il a aussi un pedigree
dans le sens où c'est le fils de jean
paul james bond et le niveau de janvier
qui sont des membres des vents
importants du côté de l'ingénieur davis
il était pas de bêtises tu peut même
remonter les générations au dessus parce
que ça c'est le petit fils de paul
qu'avec avec ses règles et arras et les
éléments au niveau jolies baskets la
cccc pousser chez eux c'est du lourd et
moi contrairement à jean christophe le
crush vu les depuis un moment j'ai une
vision d'espoir vous savez déjà adoré
bah c'est un joueur sait rien combo
guard on va dire très moderne un rapport
à ce qui se fait maintenant en nba
physiquement c'est un joueur assez
longue le longiligne assez sec et je
pense qu'il ya un peu plus athlétique
qu'il en a l'air au niveau de ses
qualités c'est ce côté scoreur 3e tour
comme on dit donc c'est à dire que ces
regards son quart à bras qui peut
enchaîner filocher à 8 mètres et qui
peut aussi aller finir dans le drive
main droite main gauche
donc c'est marrant que mu il y en ai
parlé tout à l'heure parce
qu'effectivement le footer j'ai trouvé
qu'on envoyait un peu plus s'arrêter
je trouvais rend très fort dans la
création enfin création pour lui même
justement avec toutes ces qualités là et
surtout enfin c'est le mind celles qui
dégagent terre que c'est un garçon dont
la pression qu'il n'y a rien qui ont eu
un match peu importe le score s'il
passait presque pas son problème on a
l'impression c'est un pas l'empêcher de
le prendre ses responsabilités
après attendait aussi quelques flashs à
la passe c'est le souvenir du match
contre lille si je dis pas de bêtises où
il sort ne pas c'est incroyable pour
payer nos routes
défensivement même s'il n'est pas entre
guillemets équipé pour je trouve
vraiment pas mal surtout dans la défense
au football et
je crois que c'est un truc qui devra
travailler je vais le suivre un petit
coin de bielle pour voir ce que ça peut
donner
donc voilà hugo b sens et cas d'un
garçon qui a fini donc meilleur marqueur
à 19.5 de prouver quoi pour sa première
saison donc nous donner un petit peu le
côté qualités offensives
du jeune homme
julien je tenais se compléter
ouais hugo ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'au départ il ya un an n'était pas du
tout partie là dessus ça veut dire que
l'on pouvait pas s'imaginer qu'on
parlerait ce soir pour d'éventuels nba
sec il a progressé tout au long de la
saison
il a commencé là on a commencé par un
premier match de présaison à denain un
autre modèle américain n'était pas
encore arrivé tu le sors ou de sept
minutes il est 1 sur 8 aux tirs
autant vous dire que les coéquipiers
lisez pas trop vu et l'étaler cette fois
dans le mur ensemble à poney et où il a
une grande capacité à comprendre de
basket donc ça vient évidemment de
l'éducation et ça va aussi avec parce
que défensivement je suis pas
complètement d'accord avec toi mais par
contre il connaît le basket parker donc
lino situation et du coup of the ball il
est capable d'intercepter ou deux
sonneries se positionner correctement
c'est un talent pur balle en main
un bras comme j'en ai rarement vu
moi ce qui m'a le plus impressionné la
saison dernière et c'est pas qu'ils
mettent 19 points 5 points par match
c'est qu'ils fassent 33 matches sur 34 à
plus de dix points et ça c'est assez
phénoménal ça veut dire qu'ils trouvent
toujours en moyens de secours et et
g et de partout quoi donc je pense qu'à
trois points il vaut beaucoup plus que
son pourcentage de la saison dernière
après ça va aussi avec la sélection de
tirs qui partiront à améliorer mais il
est temps d'aller chercher des petits
paniers de raccroc en jeu rapide et puis
c'est vrai on l'a vu la saison passée
il ya un peu près rien qu'ils impactent
quoi il peut jouer cette vie de 5000
personnes dix mille personnes je pense
qu'il n'y aura pas grand chose et ça ça
c'est des attitudes et une mentalité qui
peuvent lui permettre d'aller vers le
haut niveau donc moi aussi je vais
suivre attentivement ce qui va se passer
cette saison il a fait le choix de
partir avec les new zealand breakers
dans un projet qui les gens envie de le
mettre en valeur donc voilà on est très
régulièrement encore en contact avec lui
et
et on va vraiment de suivre ça parce que
encore une fois je pense que en
septembre l'année dernière on on
n'imaginait pas cela donc ça veut dire
qu'il a bossé c'est vraiment le joueur
chez duke a le plus travaillé de la
saison dernière avec très loin alors on
l'a poussé beaucoup c'est
parce que il on pense qu'il a vraiment
tout pour réussir donc et puis
physiquement tu as raison il est en fait
ça dépend comment on définit le niveau
athlétique ce qui les intéresse en effet
un vrai maître 95 on l'a fait prendre du
poids
on l'a fait beaucoup travaillé en
musculation il a fait pas les chiffres
excusez mais entre les tests de début de
saison était ce de fin de saison on n'a
plus affaire à la même personne mais il
a encore besoin coureurs vraiment tenir
les contacts et les tue elle a pris
l'idée
voilà
alors jean christophe qu'est-ce qu'on
c'était quoi le plan anti algues ou bill
sont l'année dernière voilà vous parlez
au seul coach et à qui il a ni moins de
dix points attention c'est le mandat
complet vous savez trouver vos invités
bosse sur le match à saint quentin c'est
ça c'est cette fois qu'il a mis cinq
points il me semble que ça à moi je suis
très content de son match mais
prolifique écoute
dabo d'abord chapeau bas l'artiste parce
qu'il faut les mettre les 19 points en
pro b quand même parce qu'il a mis 19
points et puis là il a aussi sorti je
crois que c'est à ces emplois il ya une
fin de match à bouaké incroyable au
niveau des tirs
et il vous met des tirs à la fin je
crois qu'il met cinq ou six tirs à 3
c'est juste après il faut féliciter
julien pour une chose
c'est que moi j'ai été témoin de la
dureté avec laquelle il a il a éduqué
hugo sur le match de coupe de france où
dès qu'il faisait une connerie il allait
sur le mans c'était incroyable c'est
incroyable cette séquence parce que il
il en remettait sur le match trois
minutes après et ça c'est voilà c'est ça
aussi former des jeunes joueurs c'est ne
faire que les mettre sur le terrain
c'est qu'à un moment comme l'a dit
julien il ya une exigence et quand tu
fais une connerie tu peux encore là
voilà moi les miens ils savent qu'ils
ont raffermi par un petit bled de temps
en temps mais mais faut pas qu'il y ait
trop non plus
écoute sur sur hugo besson a déjà les
deux premiers matches il nous a mis
beaucoup de points en coupe de france
vous avez vu beaucoup de proches et nous
aussi donc ça m'avait dit tu y es un
petit peu il me semble de mémoire et
alors je vais bientôt dire de mémoire
parce que je me rappelle plus il ya une
main sur il ya en fait il ya une main
sur laquelle il peut pas chanter
je sais plus si c'est la main il est
droitier un de mémoire incessament
droitier et il me semble qu'il peut pas
ajouter sur sa main droite en fait il a
comme beaucoup de joueurs ils ont besoin
de mettre la main sur leurs mains
faibles pour shooter et il s'en faut que
de mémoire et je te dis bien de mémoire
sur le match retour mais là je retrouve
le scouting on avait décidé d'orienter
tous les pick and roll
sur sa main droite et donc du coup
il était plus dans la création
que dans la queue dans le tir et et
semarang et est pareil sur les clauses
out sur les clauses out alors là je
parle technique ne soit tu fais des
clauses out un taux campagne parce que
le mec est pas trop tireur soit tu fais
des clauses out un peu faible parce que
le mec est entre les deux ça fait
vraiment des causes à udine et lui
pareil sur les clauses out on l'avait
orienté jeune innocente de de mémoire
sur la main droite parce qu'on avait
peur du hendrix step back ou des trucs
comme ça et là dessus il est très fort
je jouerai pas vous il me semble c'est
ça il me semble que c'était ça c'est ce
qu'on a fait et d'ailleurs c'était assez
marrant parce que
quand je revenais de la conférence de
presse pour vous situer quand même le
niveau du gamin il était sur le terrain
en train de travailler ses dribbles main
droite puisse dire
c'était rigolo ça ça va et ça m'avait
fait rigoler savez fait rigoler parce
que ça montre le drive du garçon
non il ya il ya quelque chose il ya
quelque chose moi le seul truc qui me
met c'est ce qu'a dit julien le seul
truc c'est nba ont dit tu peux jouer le
poste que tu peux défendre ouais
je sais pas aimer jeu julien ne connaît
mieux que moi je sais pas aujourd'hui
quel poste il peut défendre
leinster qui lira pas encore une fois je
je connais pas assez le joueur voit là
mais je pense qu'effectivement faut
qu'il se bâtissent un corps un corps
pour pouvoir résister à ça après ces
pousses aussi qu'en nba quand tu as du
talent qui met des points d'eau
peut-être moins de besoin de défendre
ouais ça a été notre sujet tout au long
de la saison 1
de mettre dans les règles défensives qui
soit bon qu'il est un investissement de
ce point de vue là je trouve qu'on a
vraiment vraiment vraiment progresser
avancé après nous on avait on avait mis
en place une défense qui était
collective avec vous coûter deux
défensives pour c'est ma façon de le
voir dans tous les cas mais c'est sa
protégée donc et tu vois sur le début de
saison avant le marathon on avait joué
une quinzaine de matches et on était
vraiment dans les top 3 défense de
prouver avec lui donc s'il est fondée
pas un cachou ça n'aurait pas fonctionné
et nous a longtemps mais c'est sûr que
ça va être je pense fondamentale enfin
sur les différences coutrillons qui ont
pu venir tout au long de la saison c'est
ce qui est revenue systématiquement n'ai
même pas besoin d'être côtés de billets
pour le voir donc il ya des villages
mais son investissement est en hausse et
après ça viendra aussi avec la
continuité dans le travail physique
parce que je pense qu'il est bien le jeu
donc on verra
bon messieurs on a fait le tour on va
libérer nous coach pour ce soir 19
millions d'ha 1h33 on n'est pas mal vous
parlez douce one way
simulé sinon mais moi ce que je peux
dire un truc sur ousmane je comprends
pas le choix
le choix c'est à dire son foie lits soit
une bielle
comment le choix d'aller à une belle
il va faire quoi là-bas
apprendre à parler anglais
ap ap son talent offensif comment choqué
son talent offensif montrer son talent
procès remontant
à je pense tu es ça tu m'as après ggp
alger palais j'ai pas les secrets du
dossier vtt sur un championnat après sur
l'exposition la nbl les contrats des
jeunes prospects sont pris en charge par
la ligue donc je pense qu'il ya une
logique économique est derrière très
économique voilà il ya ça
la ligue a la chance contrairement à
d'autres ligues européennes et qu'on
connaît d'avoir un diffuseur qui a un
deal avec la télé us avec qui espionnent
donc je pense que tu as tu tues le gic
d'agents derrière d'exposition
bon nous on amasse laurent ventilons
lesbiennes quoi si tu veux je pensais
tout une logique économique derrière qui
rentrent en ligne de compte a pas de
choix basket il faut être confiant on va
moi et nous on était sur houston ont
joui
nous allions vite nous trois quatre fois
il ya du boulot c'est un chantier là il
faut pas faire que du showcase faut y
aller dans la salle parce que le dribble
des métros le tir il est moyen le
physique pour le bâtir complètement
après il ya un potentiel de malades on
est tous d'accord il a un sens de la
passe incroyable ce garçon lui
l'anticipation mais yahia chantier de
chez chantiers il ya deux ans de travail
c'est un mai 2003 donc
ouais mais ça va vite en échec à nyon
rock la draft est passé l'année d'après
il ya une nouvelle draft en
serbie
je regarde déjà pas comme des mois m à
voir donc
la
captation onemola là d'un petit peu
patraque c'était juste une aparté sur
ousmane mais je vais pas vous embêter
jusqu'ici tous manon mais est ce qu est
ce que les équipes de proies de bbq
kelly aurait pu la lui offrir les mêmes
le même environnement de développement
vu la réaction du geste et je pense que
les équipes c'est bah oui oui les
équipes je peux pas te dire je ne peux
pas parler des autres moi les autres je
sais pas comment ils travaillent et mai
mais oui
parce qu'elle est belle en plus du
salaire qui est vrai en champions league
aussi je crois le le coach de
développement qui prit inquiets qui est
pris en charge par l'adie est un
développeur au code suis mais je vire
kulik peut avoir des projets de
développement mais nous on a deux
préparateurs physiques on a deux qui le
trailer on a trois et deux assistants on
a une prof de yoga je pense qu'on est
pas mal
non
par contre vous l'a dit nationale
tchèque prend rien charles si vous
voulez quoi
c'est à strasbourg
narva écoute je sais pas mais si on part
sur un autre sujet là mais
on veut on peut bien on peut bien
déconner après 1h30 de à oui oui
complètement main ou en réalité c'est un
bon débat parce que cette année il ya
les six joueurs qui ont rejoint la ligne
aile d'europe pour mais dans le même
projet que que jen ya rien apporté à une
petite amie railhawks qui a
gobé son il y en a d'autres parce que
depuis 2 3 de trois ans la nba les amis
des joueurs nba ça va pas plus loin que
ça et donc c'est comme ça va vendre sa
ont joué près que tu veux que je te
donne leur salaire je sais que moi mais
je parle viviane économique et primaires
mais aussi la une idée et je dis pas que
c'est bien je pense que ce faire ça
m'embête wikileaks comme des les joueurs
du paris basket se font cette année
c'est très très bien parce que c'est
même mieux parce qu'au niveau de
compétition match après match et bien
plus d'intensité bien plus intéressante
mais ce qui est réel ses clés
vend à des prospects le fait que depuis
trois ans
l'addl a mis trois jours au premier tour
je le fais pas je le mets pas et encore
une fois il n'ya pas que le paris basket
ball ça peut être strasbourg ça peut
être il ya plein d'endroits ils
travaillent et gravelines a fait du bon
travail il ya plein d'enfants je dis
juste que
je te plaît dommage que gamma femme tu
sais c'est comme l'équipe qui sont en
train de créer c'est in each pas quoi
comme la vie indignes arron revient au
débat il ya s'essayer cci nice c'est un
ligne 7bis oui bon tous vouloir ce
showcase et tu as il ya même des scouts
et n'diaye qui qui te disent
c'est nul donc bien sûr contre et en
europe aussi les névés this fait ça on
est soigné ok là bas ça va être en fait
une cible même provoqué la balle pour
chacun se montrer ils vont pas prendre
le basket des différences alan fait que
la date choisie chef français basile
asie là la différence tu vois tu me
parles de névé jce c'est comme égal et
max on est tombé sur des gens et le club
en europe ou fait des agents qui sont
derrière c'est pas tout à fait pareil
mais pour moi il ya un problème de fond
pour le basket français aussi qui n'a
pas été anticipée pourtant par les
entraîneurs connaissent les départs de
jeunes se font de plus en plus tôt de
plus en plus nombreux également et on a
une vraie une vraie entre guillemets
fuite de prospecter vers l'étranger tu
sois des prospects qualité comme dieng
des joueurs de standing intermédiaires
qui partant initiée par la case du cow
boys culutre questions à se poser sur la
formation sur la préformation et
charasse formation en france aussi qui
devrait qui est pas encore relaté de
dirigeants mais qu'il variables depuis
longtemps je crois
et il faut se réveiller sur une chose et
c'est que aujourd'hui il faut pas rêver
1,6 et en france on a en fait on a une
et demie d'or ce que tu prends la
génération 2001 mais tu prends la
génération 2007 2008 chp respecte les
sites et là c'est juste monstrueux les
2009 en les appelant à regarder mais tu
verras sera pareil en fait et cette mine
d'or aujourd'hui bata des agences
étrangères qui met au basket la faire
c'est les premiers alors à fait si elles
sont en train d'arriver sur la recherche
puisque dieng cessiez et
il y en a un paquet qui sont chez eux
mais donc il laisse moi en france parce
qu'en france est trop dangereux aussi
ils n'ont pas de contrôle des gamins en
france sont pas là et il ya des agents
français autour c'est il faut
phocéen c'est un vrai vraiment un
problème pour moi c'est un vrai problème
pour moi un gamin qui sort de lindsay et
qui
sait mais là c'est un problème peut-être
de la fédération française de basket
parce que le gamin pendant deux ans
c'est là c'est nous qui allons payer
mais c'est aussi con que c'est l'âge
c'est un sujet qu'il faudra un jour
abordé parce que parce que parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est
je trouve pas ça normal quoi parce qu'en
plus il y a des bons formateurs en
france quand il y en a dans tous les
clubs il y en a dans tous les clubs
c'est pas trop tellement c'est beau
l'asvel fait affaire a fait du bon
travail vous avez fait du bon travail à
la sig avec avec le petit le petit
tchicamboud ses dires il ya plein de
clubs regardent le match opposant le
mans il en faire ils ont fait du travail
ils ont prétexté charbel l'an dernier
donc à un moment avec cette eau si tu
vois on serait on serait on serait pas
bon j'ai pas de souci à un moment où
alors on est vraiment bien google non
mais on en revient à ce que je disais
tout à l'heure dans le cas de vos deux
projets clubs respectifs c'est à dire
qu'à mon à l'autre c'est au dessus nous
c'est à dire si c'est pas une logique de
coach dusan diag tu nous le mal à six
grands comptes je pense que la ci et là
s'il prend il fait jouer tous les jours
c'est pas l'agression c'est un problème
c'est un problème dont l'institution est
ce un problème de projets on a un projet
sur ces choses là et c'est un tort parce
que notre marché aujourd'hui si tu dis
que championnat australien il a 20
millions de dollars de droits télé via
lesbiennes si la digue et ac.b a pu
signer le droit avec qui et ce piano
fille je vois pas pourquoi nous
championnat france cas car un basket qui
peut se prêter se rapprocher d'un jeu
nba et qui est identifiable parce que
beaucoup prospects n'arrive pas à vendre
les choses c'est le problème c'est la
stratégie le stratège c'est toujours
pareil
c'est à dire mais si j'ai vous couper
parce que ce débat là on devrait l'avoir
assez prochainement dans l'émission
savoir justement sur la problématique de
ses joueurs français qui
qui s'exilent
utile au moins leurs talents ailleurs
donc ce sera une thématique à venir très
certainement on a déjà coché
essais et je me permets je vois juste
une question sur tom digbeu en fait tom
dit qu il voulait venir chez nous parce
que je connais bien alain mais on
n'avait pas de temps de jeu à lui offrir
parce que je suis à leurs données
et donc 8ème digbeu est parti là-bas
aussi
allez salut jeu léché les bottes pas
tout dire à gérard collomb et puis elle
est d'habiter vous plaisir si vous êtes
dispo la porte est ouverte bien
évidemment
personne n'avait pas sûr merci marty et
bon courage et bonne chance pour les
prochains matches mercer de jeu
merci
bon pierre va pouvoir parler de
d'ousmane king donc je crois moi je
reste avec vous je la veux je change mes
rides au chocolat
roman bien sûr
toujours à nos jours
les pierres
on va finir avec a du coup ce man
une des têtes de lance de la génération
2002 donc qui compte que qu'on a vu avec
les travaux les yoann et armelle traoré
à l'insep
quels jouets souvent en équipe de france
et à l'insep avec victor wanyama
avec les jeunes âges à sa revue père
qui viennent de quitter du coup lindsay
pour rejoindre les new zealand poker en
n&b elle
donc c'est un
grand poste 2 il faudra sûrement encore
définir son poste mais comme le dit
allen sera sûrement sur plus sur un rôle
qui va falloir travailler
grand il est annoncé entre 2,01 et sur
le site de lindsey bled de 0,6 sur
internet avec une vraie grande envergure
à vue de nez je dirai au moins deux
mètres 15 il a des bras vraiment
extrêmement long comme je disais il joua
il alterne entre le poste de le poster
avec plutôt un rôle de
porteur de balle et de finisseur en
catch and shoot sur sur les dernières
années tu passes en un an alors j'ai
j'ai appliqué les conseils de l'aisne de
regarder les anciens match quand même du
joueur donc du 16 au jeu de rôle
pour elle consulting où on a pu le roux
a envoyé un peu plus évolués comme dieu
comme comme comme un shooter un vrai un
vrai ailier ou arrière shooteur une
dimension du catch and shoot
voilà donc
où est ce qu'on peut le voir plus tard
moi je le vois bien soit être un très
grand très en arrière qui va qui va
apporter beaucoup au scoring ou un poste
3 en fonction de son développement
physique
déjà de m 6 à 18 ans
encore beaucoup de masse a ajouté ça va
sûrement le travail sur l'année où les
deux années qui arrive ce sera sûrement
à ceux à ce niveau on voit que ça le
limite quand même un petit peu
déjà en jeunes il ya deux ans sur les
sur les contacts avec l'intérieur est un
peu un peu moins c'est vrai sur sur la
fin de la saison en l1
avec une projection
si on est optimiste
fait de l'autre de loterie début de
début de 2ème partie de draft autour de
25 je pense que ça devrait pas être
déconnant pour un joueur avec l'hôtel
tel potentiel
et ce qui va le faire vendre ce sera
surtout la création de tout pour
lui-même on va pas se le cacher c'est un
seul joueur qui va apporter au scoring
pour lui en utilisant le pick and roll
c'est encore quelque chose qui va devoir
à apprendre on le voit est
abordé des gros volumes de tirs à 1 400
tout un peu moins 100 poules up mais
avec une réussite qui suit pas forcément
mes 18 ans et en heure il était déjà à
12,6 points avec après seulement 33 % de
réussite
et après toi est ce que je disais
jean-christophe la passe comme élément
premier de sa première qualité
il est là il est sûre les sur toutes ces
années où on a des stats sur sûr c'est
sur ces compétitions il ya toujours plus
de turn over que de deux passes
décisives et alors qu'ils jouent et
quand même avec wen jiabao et les deux
traoré balle voilà d'aider des gens qui
on pouvait donner le ballon surtout
quand on l'a on à victor dans son équipe
il ya une vraie bonne relation mais sait
jamais hein c'est pas un joueur qui en
soit n'est pas encore le cui qui est
assez développé soit qu'il ya peut-être
eu une vision en tunnel pour aller
marquer qui est pas encore qui veut pas
encore créé pour les autres ni sur
pick'n roll ni sur création ballom
ont battu l'as vu un petit peu ousmane
dieng
a gelé vu jouer un petit peu long
dernier jeu les vue puisque bon voir des
matches de l1 c'est pas quelque chose
qui est toujours très facile et surtout
charia partie de saison où ça s'est un
petit peu accéléré mais je les ai vus
et je les ai vus globalement web plutôt
plutôt sur la fin de saison que je
m'étais renseigné un petit peu sur le
sur lui sur le dossier pour savoir un
peu comment était le joueur bon par
curiosité pour pour nous pourquoi
réglementer un petit peu aussi j'avais
déjà vu quelques quelques personnes qui
m'avaient tu avais regardées moi c'est
un profil que c'est un profil que j'aime
bien si vous mais c'est juste de
retrouver les notes que j'avais
ce que l'armée drame au drame en direct
du toit nos auditeurs
je peux rajouter que c'est un petit peu
plus facile de trouver des des matchs en
fin d'année sur youtube sur youtube de
la fédération sur les sur les sur les
sites internet sur les facebook des
autres équipes en on a une cinq six
matches au moins qui sont qui sont
trouvables
ousmane dieng mais par contre en europe
il ya un seul match qui est qui est
disponible de sa campagne en ont eu 16
ans en 2019 contre la serbie toutes les
autres toulousains ya très peu de matchs
de ce championnat d'europe clara qui
sont sur youtube mais il ya quand même
il ya des il ya des matches où la
qualité bas et pas dégueulasse à trouver
et on peut observer vraiment pas mal de
pas mal de prospects dans l'est dans la
même équipe que ce soit à l'insep ou en
équipe de france ddd joueurs qui sont
déjà partis en acier ou qui évolue
encore à une clé beaucoup sont en net
repli bientôt un ouais
non contre contrairement à ce que dit
julien non je sors pas les dossiers mais
c'était le temps de retrouver les notes
que j'avais que j'avais sur lui
sur les infos qu'on m'avait qu'on
m'avait qu'on m'avait donné sur les d
intel globalement sont bons sur le sur
le sur le bonhomme est sûre la la
qualité de travail du joueur que c'est
plutôt un mec qui est pas très
extraverti mais très bien éduqué ses
[Musique]
capacités à bosser quéréel
les interrogations que que j'avais
l'étais plus
moi sur la sur la dureté un petit peu
sur la capacité à défendre des joueurs
plus petits mois c'est essentiellement
des choses liées aux aspects aux aspects
un petit peu défensif parce que le
globalement les outils les outils
techniques qu'ils les à la compréhension
de tuiles basket tout ça c'est des
choses qui la pareille le problème d'ego
de deux choses comme ça une personne est
libre et les personnalités pardon et
livrer les coaches abl mais c'était
juste voilà c'est un joueur qui a
progressé sur le fait de tenir et gagner
des duels on peut switcher un petit peu
maintenant avec lui sur des joueurs de
de niveau n1 prouver ou sur des joueurs
de sa catégorie c'est des choses qui
passait mais pour plus haut c'est sait
des choses c'est les choses à voir après
je pense que les unes qui sont là mais
c'est toujours cette question qu'on se
pose sur les joueurs sur la sur la sur
la sur la dureté sur la capacité à
vraiment se mettre dans le rouge c'est
un petit quelque chose la question se
pose la question se pose c'est je dis
pas que ça arrête fly du tout bien au
contraire mais mais la question se pose
d'importants du lycée mondiale 9/10
ultra talentueux offensivement
je trouve franchement
c'est un genre que mini cette date a
capela quasiment de mettre à 100 ans à
son âge donc c'est tout de suite ça
attire l'oeil parce qu'en plus il pleut
il ya parfois si le pool ap pas à pas
pas affreux
ouais c'est plus défensivement au dessus
de demande quel profil il va défendre
déjà en nba je sais le contexte new
zealand et à peyton siva ego besson dans
l'équipe ça veut dire que c'est des deux
porteurs de balle de l'équipe donc c'est
intéressant parce qu'on pourra peut-être
voir où se vendent dans un rôle
différent un rôle de peut-être spotters
shooter deuxième créateur c'est à dire
il est pas celui qui initie mais que
c'était un rôle de finisseur holder qui
prend des décisions mises en mouvement
ça c'est intéressant puisqu'on pouvoir
comparer
comme ça on pourra voir attendre
différents rôles ensuite
moi je la question que je demande c'est
ce que c est ce que c'est dès cette
année c'est la question principale je
pense parce que 6 mai 2003 il peut se
présenter à la draft qui serait un des
dès 2003 c'était plus jeune de la
prochaine cuvée est ce que c'est pour
cette année et parce que pour l'instant
des gros joueurs ayant signé donc le
fameux contrat et joueur étoile donc
c'est ce qui le contrat qu'à signer ce
mondial ces jours là on se sont pas
éternisés en nba et alison la mélo ball
gardien anton
voilà jeudi avoir présenté un australien
donc j'espère
champy donne un signal c'est un peu
différent qu'on voit c'est ça même si en
vrai c'était un peu la même chose je
peux les autres qui sont arrivés cette
année en nba les autres joueurs qui ont
cosigné c'est juste contrats sont plus
âgés que
ousmane diagne mots qu'on peut dire
c'est vraiment la dernière année où ou
qu'il y aura moins de temps y por ti
besson mirail look skid digbeu si jamais
le présente à la draft ou d'autres de
ces jours-là y en a d'autres journaux
publient d'ailleurs mais voilà ce que la
question c'est est ce que une saison de
nba avec où je pense un fouillis dire
aux gens et aux joueurs car mgr john
n'avait rôles secondaires voire terceira
dans une équipe dans l'équipe de
débreaker
tout le monde n'est pas là mais lowball
tout le monde n'arrive pas une bielle et
joue 30 noeuds de moyenne et génère
toutes les attaques déjà si tu fais ça
ton club
ne gagnera pas énormément de matches
parce que ça un joueur de 18 ans qui est
le ton aux options une de partout c'est
compliqué je pense mais je peignais va
avoir un rôle secondaire voire terrain
est-ce que après ça il leur a tout
montré assez pour lui pour se dire je me
présente à la draft la question j'ai vu
les enjeux financiers et vu
l'investissement qui a été fait sur le
gamin et par l'agencé par là par la nbl
- autriche sera exposée jointes ne vont
pas comment ça peut ça peut se passe
autrement c'est toujours pareil les gens
que tu les gens que tu payes
tu m sur le t1 moi je ne paye pas pour
rien c c c du suicide économique je
pense que la l'aller les choix des
choses ont été faites dans ce sens là
après le foie le choix moi c'est ce que
l'état leur moi je suis plus d'âge rien
vous cacher gens parlent encore avec jc
ans en échange la part message moi je
trouve je trouve anormal que le problème
auquel on est confronté à des coûts se
manie avec me connaître avec d'autres
prospects bientôt c'est à dire qu' on
n'est pas une capacité alors la capit
économique jules et vu les sommes on va
pas c'est certain mais au moins les
projets je veux dire le boulot le boulot
de julien le boulot jc le boulot
d'autres coach pourra pour développer
faire jouer des jeunes joueurs blois
aussi à fait ça
voilà il ya plein d'entraîneurs et plein
de clubs qui se pètent dans cet état
d'esprit là à tour cette année aussi il
ya quand même pas mal de pas mal de
jeunes intéressants soient
battus jusqu'au bout
dans tintin dans un registre différent
foule amassée des jeunes joueurs c'est
bien de le faire mais à un moment un
moment c'est ça doit partir dans ça va
partir dans roue je vais pas dire que
c'est le boulot de trail bout de ligne
de le faire mais pour moi pour moi il le
projet les initiatives doit partir dans
l'histoire du nombre d'étrangers oui
c'est les facteurs de lutte en avoir
moins d'étrangers dans les championnats
notablement cellectis de place pour les
yesha d'instituer donc le problème mais
bon c'est l'autre débat temps de parler
de tas leurs pierres on aura le problème
pour moi c'est qu'il faut à moins d'être
capable d'avoir quelque chose à proposer
assez lent après ils refusaient refuse
mais au moins il ya quelque chose à
mettre sur la table de de cohérent
d'argumenter de structurer et pour
garder le jeune choix mais il ya aussi
une histoire de résultats là ndlr elle
et elle a réussi à faire son beurre sur
ce que tu disais à la fois là réussi à
faire son beurre sur le sont en
formation de joueurs en très peu de
temps voilà il faut il va falloir
réussir à un manager des ego à manager
les encourager à avoir des résultats
voile avant que les que les que les
jeunes reprennent confiance en la
première division française pour se
lancer pour se lancer pour lancer leur
carrière professionnelle comme comme ça
a été le cas avec la laine belle ils ont
réussi à ils ont réussi à voir
ils ont eu un succès ils ont capitalisé
dessus est-ce que là est ce que la sq
après en france on va vouloir faire la
même chose qu on adorait on a pu voir
déjà avec la pro b que ça marchait bien
est-ce qu'il faut que
la pro b j ai passé que j'ai passé j'ai
passé six saisons en pro b
il ya des clubs comme comme loi j'en
parle souvent l'issue pas ces gens que
je connais je connais je connais bien
julien monclar et quelques mots là où ça
a était au départ un petit peu comme
julien d'expliquer tout à l'heure à
saint quentin il n'y a pas de centre de
formation agréé donc il faut des moins
de 23 ans si si tu respecte le règlement
stricto sensu tu dis bros je prends des
gamins je mets le reste de mon pognon
sur mes joueurs étrangers je prends de
jfl les quatre fronts la mallet
compagnie sauf que si tu es intelligent
tu fais ce que c'est que la bouffe est
tu vas chercher des gamins que tu vas
fidéliser sur deux trous
que tu va développer et au final des
joueurs ça devient les variables
d'ajustement
c'est à dire que des variables positif
c'est à dire que en fonction de
l'évolution de ces joueurs là ton équipe
elle va monter elle va monter au
classement elle va gagner plus de matchs
parce que la progression se forment et
j'arrive pack wii c'est du sport de
ligue 2 le mans mais il y à il ya un
étranger en trop pour moi en pro b il ya
un étranger en trop pour moi en
proie et et tout part de l'armée c'est
à dire ayant
il jurait qu'il nous sort des noms sur
le diable de ne pas trop en ce moment
dans les grosses écuries
hamé traoré de venise même est-ce que
c'est des joueurs qui auraient eu
intérêt à choisir une autre option aussi
ccd équipe de céder équipe d'euroligue
il s'entraîne tous les jours avec
avec avec des amis trovic qui est pour
moi qui ai un cours de référence est
quand même il ya déjà développé des gens
je pense que au jour d'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui notamment cesser ces
cellules c'est lui qui a lancé qui a
lancé m strazeele un petit peu et et
comme monty jay parker fait un excellent
boulot avec l'asvel et il dit plusieurs
fois la saison dernière seulement une
saison en ligue 2 ont gentiment taper en
demi-finale du championnat mais surtout
baisse de laisse une équipe qui joue
bien qui développe des gens et je vois
jouer à matthew joué cette année ben
voilà dans la continuité de ce qu'ils
avaient fait mitrovic didier parker le
fait également voilà une fille fait
jouer les gamins et pour en revenir aux
deux d'entre eux parlé à monaco guy
lacombe a joué une soixantaine de
matches cette année et tôt ou tard les
joueurs auront leur place après la
stratégie de monaco est différente mais
est ce que c'est un mauvais choix des
dans une grosse structure avec un
entraîneur référencé au niveau et
français et européen et une capacité à
se développer dans des bonnes conditions
il manque peut-être les minutes d'accord
ils montrent les minutes mais d'un autre
côté ils voient ce que c'est que le très
haut niveau il y a pas de bon ou de
mauvais choix j'ai donc faire la tirade
edouard baer d'astérix
y'a pas y'a pas de bonnes et mauvaises
situations l'essentiel c'est que les
gens avancent et que les joueurs soient
respectées pour savoir comment ce dès
2003 vie de travail tout à l'heure tout
à l'heure jc parler de son expérience
avec erman kunter csda mitrovic est
pareil et j'ai travaillé nikola antic
champ il lui faut aussi qu'ils sont
pareils c'est chaque joueur ils ont beau
avoir des noms différents ils sont
chargés de lignes au départ et les gens
travaillent exactement et julien dit
gamal est d'un mois si les dons ont été
lancés la même façon donc voilà c'est à
dire que d'exemples y en a plein le
contexte après c'est le choix du joueur
mais encore une fois monaco c'est monaco
on sauf qu'ils ont proposé à deux jeunes
joueurs de venir parce qu'il leur
fallait un quota de jfl etc etc oui on
pensait aussi mais en attendant les
clubs proposent et les gens ils ont donc
peut-être aussi bien dans la mode la
poubelle en australie même si les
perspectives sont différents oui 2 1
soit il faut traoré il faut attendre à y
aller quand même temps de l'abstention
il sort de deux noeuds là il va il va
s'entraîner avec des mecs qui jouent en
euroligue qui vont jouer trois fois par
semaine parfois c'est c'est pas parce
que sur le sur les six premiers mois il
n'a pas encore joué à quinze minutes par
match que ça va pas marcher de mahi
l'année dernière il a fini il a fait une
super prouvé sur petit à petit où il a
pris du temps de jeu en eurocoupe il a
été responsabilisé sur les sur les
plaines match et puis là il a start et
pas mal de matches dans les phases
finales c'est un projet qui est très
intéressant pour un club qui accueille
quand même des grosses ambitions et
qu'il ne peut pas se permettre de perdre
du temps entre guillemets sur le
développement des jeunes
pour finir sur une bonne vieille je vous
partirez sur une draft conte du coup
plus tout ce dont vous
pointe de
22000 val d'aucy là le 6 le si le
physique a déjà prouvé c'est qu'il ait
au moins une saison avoir une demi
saison de nba pour encore passé à notre
notre cas une équipe va trop de talent
de jeunesse le prendre les coups vont
dîner
je te fuis la réponse de normand on en
reparle en trois mois c'est quelque
chose qui venait mais en plus on imagine
assez de commandes championne
australienne à se dérouler bascule mais
quand même il ya quelques semaines
c'était encore au niveau sanitaire un
petit peu bancal notamment pour les
circulations entre les régions et
séparés et c'est donc on en reparle on
en reparle en janvier et en janvier en
janvier je pense que tu tu peux
commencer à y voir plus clair parce que
vu l'investissement dossier sur le gamin
ils vont pas s'amuser non plus à jeter
dans le bain si une agence qui est super
influent donc y compris les joutes par
hasard mais ils s'amuseront pas acheter
un joueur comme ça dans le bain avec
investissements qui sont faits dessus
tiens on a tout dit sur ce mondial
je pense qu'on a été bon je pense qu'on
a été grossie messieurs on va s'arrêter
là ça fait deux heures 01 encore une
fois dans le timing on est très bien
donc on boit ça va être le moment de
vous remercier ceux qui nous ont suivis
fin de ce deuxième épisode de paille
draft donc rendez vous au mois prochain
pour un nouvel épisode oubliez pas de
vous abonner à la chaîne activer les
cloches consulter régulièrement notre
site envergure on a tous les jours on a
des articles qui sort le sud est hier
c'était son pack bing junior je crois
qu'ils étaient très intéressants un gros
prospects qui envoie une petite fac aux
mets dans le resort conférence je crois
un grand remerciement à tous les invités
qui sont venus
julien mahé du spv jean christophe prat
du paris basket ball bien dire
basketball et yakhouba diawara
qui nous a gratifié d'une magnifique
visite de son garage
shootout à toute la team envergure vous
les connaissez alex ben magnini qu
antoine antoine vieille julien et steve
maximy lessines qui ont tous contribué
de près ou de loin à cette émission qui
met reçus avec à ceux qui sont là à
l'aan pierre weill et du coup et romain
merci les gars on se retrouve très vite
pour un prochain épisode de près notre
salut